[Music]
welcome everyone to the football
tournament presented by the sports
gambling podcast my bookie Todd AG and
all things comedy I'm Sean stack in the
mud agreement with my partner picks
write real money Cramer what's happened
to cramdown long story short I saw some
real men some forest fighter fire fires
over the weekend fighters I'm sorry Sean
and I saw the chainsaw dudes those are
some bad MF errs so let's go I'm ready
for the football tournament after seeing
that I'm a man ready to get my units
back jacked up ready to go joining us as
always third man in the booth number one
in your hearts Colby dant aka the Dan to
bass what's happening Colby I didn't see
any forest fires it might a lit a few
fires and a few females you know yeah
I'm doing great
we are back here doing the football
tournament again shout-out to people
watching on the all things comedy
YouTube if you're wondering what the
hell is this we'll explain it
we're basically going to be simulating
Madden games we're gonna be doing the
play-by-play and by simulating it means
the computer is going to play the
computer we're not playing at all
completely just simulate a game and the
great thing is you could bet on these
games live so there there are spreads
for these games
there are player props for these games
and all you got to do is go to my bookie
dot AG use the promo code TFT
that's for the football tournament and
deposit over there you get a sweet
deposit bonus and lay down some pets man
it I if you're hesitant if you go what
the hell am I doing with my life I'm
watching video games trust us it's fun
grab a cocktail if you're already drunk
that's even better have a couple drinks
if you're if you're the proclivity of
smoking the weed yeah vices in the house
I'm sure I mean look I was a skeptic
coming into this I've had a blast I love
doing it even when I'm not calling the
games I'm at home I'm gambling on these
things you tell the girlfriend hey I'm
gonna bring in some extra income it's
simple thing right everyone needs a side
hustle right now if we are offering the
ultimate side hustle because it feels
like betting on football games Sean this
game is scheduled to start at 5:10
Pacific 810 on the East Coast so you
still have seven minutes to get those
wagers in Sean we have a special
surprise even for the regulars player
props baby playoffs ornament the player
props come out over at my bookie JG
again promo code TFT and Seana I figured
I'll throw it to you you're up you're
the man up six units you're the man on
the high castle right now so I get it I
get a pick the side see what I did that
I'm up six units I'm gonna I'm gonna
throw another two units on the New
Orleans Saints layin six and a half the
New Orleans Saints if you watch you Sims
and we've watched a ton of these New
Orleans Saints are just outright sim
God's like whatever it is about drew
Brees man drew Brees he gets it done cam
Jordan is a dominant force and the
Vikings they came in in the 2019 NFL
playoffs and got the upset this is what
we're basically redoing they're not
gonna get the upset here in in the sim
world they're Madden does not like the
Viking Sims Kolby you're an outfit guy
do we go throw backs tonight do we go
color rush Vikings it's hard to make any
of them look good but uh yeah yeah guess
great face mask so we just go let's go
full white we got Daniel a Pharrell
chicken in the youtubes a atc st. bench
drew Brees for Jameis Winston I wish
we're huge fans of
Jameis Winston here on the sports game
so that we've nicknamed him Jameson
Winston because of much like Jamison
Jamison a lot of interceptions a lot of
touchdowns and we're sipping on some
Jameson here in the studio I'm actually
I'm going beer here tonight but yeah
check in let me know what you guys are
working on what you guys are betting
what you're rooting for we'll be doing
some old besides the free play that you
can win from the tournament and if
you're in the tournament just go to
sports gambling podcast com slush a TC
can see where you're at in the
leaderboard we're gonna be doing some
bonus player props
this is proves we're not we're not these
weirdos playing video games on the
Internet
we're the weirdos watching video games
on the internet and betting on it and
just give it a chance you will get
hooked especially if you're degenerate
as we call ourselves the player props
really burned me last week so I'm are
you staying away cuz I think everyone
wants to know what you can see in this
first game we still have four minutes to
get down the Kramer gangs are already
down on the Vikings I'm not sure how I
like about this you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna stay 6:30 just so the Kirk
Cousins Kirk Cousins in prime time is
not someone I want to bet on I'm gonna
take the under and Michael Thomas and a
half catches really cuz they have cook
they don't that logic I got burned by
Julian Edelman you know let's eat you
throw it so you're going under Michael
Thomas receptions at seven and a half
marked that down Colby has been a real
mush when it comes to the the city the
player props Kramer what do you like for
the player prop action here ah well I
got a do something for fun on my guys
let's go Kirk Cousins over two hundred
sixty eight and a half yards Wow her
cousin Wow your boy your boy your back
guys throw for 300 yards like nothing at
sim they have a good wow look Jared cook
aka the sim got his catch total yeah
they're getting smart it said it ate but
under is minus 140 what did you do there
I feel like it's pretty dead accurate
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna go
uh I'm gonna go under
Rudolph receiving yards singing and I
feel like he's not involved he's not
Jewish games he went to Notre Dame you
know what uh you know how dare you hey
he's a tight end it won't the gate and
Madden in the game love tight ends that
could come back to haunt me I'll go and
said Alvin Kamara under seventy seven
and a half rushing yards Oh interesting
the Saints don't run the ball a ton it
when they get going it's it's just all
involved in the passing game I mean he
could have a big game receiving the pulp
but I don't see him running for 78 yards
did I get introduced this pick Dundee
because that means I am I am putting a
hex on my pick then because you have a
Saints right I do have the same can't
fade jarred cook your dad beautiful you
you uh Sean must you I don't think it
matters it would pick Dundee when it
comes to the Saints you know I mean I
think the same sir is that good they're
that good of sim God's it's it's just
raising a brazen Gator fans checking in
on the my bookie man twitch page saying
SGP good running back discussion earlier
he's of course talking about her top ten
fantasy football running back podcast we
just dropped that make sure to check
that out you got to check out the Jerry
Glanville episode that was an all time
or Jerry Glanville was some of the just
some of the best stories I've ever heard
in the sports world and he's just this
old coach he's 78 years old still racing
cars still still like racing for NASCAR
we got a hit a race and and while we are
great Sean yes we should also give a
little credit to the man sitting between
us oh the man in the sandwich right now
no no no worries I know you like the
sandwich you're never and you're never
to be in the sandwich though call me
you are breaking down all 130 Division
one college football teams one team at a
time tell the people what team you you
up to you're up to Miami I think right
we just finished Miami I know I think I
was dropping as we're talking right now
so you definitely want to head over to
wherever you get those podcasts find the
college experience Joey Mason checking
in on the YouTube ATC you checking
out Joey nice Joey I'm not I'm not soft
you can come at me come
me with the hate that's fun own a 3d for
you who the hell are these guys I'll
tell you who the hell we are with a
sports gambling podcast Brian Rodriguez
saying have bill burr on your podcast we
have had bill burr on the podcast many a
times for talking to NFL football a big
contract for Showtime mahomes just give
him the franchise I love that video
of the equipment staff rushing in with
the bed the Chiefs bags just bags of
cash baby all right we got it's kickoff
time Sean should we go yeah why not
Skeletor here to tell us it's time
Skeletor where yet roll Magic Man any of
the usuals Jarek cook time dick girth
Gertz burger Toby's favorite I've ran
that by I'm like tonight Shawn 20m geez
it is a Tuesday all right let's get this
going let's do it you of course watching
the football tournament presented by my
bookie Todd Agee sports gaming podcast
and all things comedy let's do this
I'm jacked up for this game and then we
got the we got a great late game as well
Eagles Seahawks again running back the
2019 NFL playoffs
what's that spread Shaun Eagles still a
home dog they are they are disrespectful
it is here we go let's get this audio
piped up in this let's go baby
committee live from the mercedes-benz
Superdome Kirk Cousins used to playing
in a dome big time revenge spot Saints
we'll start with the ball okay nice
return okay in the twenty nine Colby
what side of the game are you on the
year I guess in six-man - yeah okay come
on - six and a half it was it was seven
and a half maybe I'd think but I mean
come on cook is a god blackout I mean I
think these UT's look good not as good
as
blech that's what I needed force
the ball early and into double coverage
incomplete second and ten and that's
Hendrix who was coached in college and
recruited by Jim Moret jr. and if you're
just tuning in a couple minutes late
like Sean pointed out head over to my
bookie AG promo code TFT live spreads
the number right now still six and a
half shown Saints are six and half point
favorites at home here second and ten
breeze back to throw deep ball
complete and he too seen this from Drew
Brees in spite of the fact that they won
our earlier Madden tournament they've
had moments where Drew Brees looks
really off if he eventually figures it
out it's a flood he said moments where
he looks horrible that was Chad
Pennington right there look two plays
two targets to cook you can really try
to force him in and the under uncooked
catches already looking good 1310
brewing out of the shack to talk about
these things not looking good Raekwon
Smith in the Vikings territory for a
first down and the New Orleans Saints on
the move 30 yard throw and that's the
Drew Brees we need to see Colby if we
want to cover the six and a half points
per definitely definitely he has not
looked great so far but I feel like the
Vikings missed a couple good
opportunities right there jedi master
coming in say I'm the YouTube ATC
the NFL Wow okay sorry it's not Star
Wars Star Wars guy lets a text okay if
you want to see some light sabers sabers
that's later that's the late-night show
over on twitch twitch TV slash sports
gambling podcast
incomplete pass for Brees second and ten
first at our start second and 10 from
the 41 breeze out of the shotgun
back to throw wasn't it Michael late
let's Emmanuel Sanders of the first down
now breeze two four five but he has 42
yards two first downs that guy's pissed
at the NFL he's probably one of those
NBA China guys you know I mean all right
Daniel checking in on you the HCC
YouTube saying Brees at a rhythm now
that the black room finds him who finds
finds him aids lately Wow he did lose
some of his saloons teammates with the
controversial statements about the flag
but he seems to rally the troops and
another completion another first down to
Michael Thomas David parently patched
things up that's his first catch though
Eric J saying can you gamble on these
games yes you can just go to my bookie
data AG use that promo code TFT get in
on the action they go live betting and
you just click on the sidebar their
sports simulations first and 10 breezing
the Saints on the move in the red that's
just wow talk I was about to throw the
shades on Sean I'm glad I did won't meet
him today cuz I'm on the side did they
did they Ruby that hair no how did none
of these Saints guy horrible and look at
Mike Simmons got a dip in the eye patch
can I give you my theory on what
happened there Brees throws the pick
team not interested in helping them say
no really not and maybe that's that
locker room dissension oh it's getting
chippy out there wow this is a learning
computer right so maybe maybe they
updated and gave rise a little bit of a
worse he looks like and and now now
it's time for the defense to come out
remember the Saints do have seen God I
mean they get the ball back oh you're
right I would just saw anal zone and I
got I was gonna do my whole anal zone
zone Provo and now they're gonna update
the live line over my book EDG promo
code TFT but there is going to be
tremendous value on the Saints teams
down
Shawn the live number Saints - three and
a half plus 105 - 195 on the money line
Vikings plus 135 53 is the total you got
Alex uh Cunningham checking in can we
put bounties on players you know what
yeah we can next player that gets
injured $25 free player will be up for
grabs love it
we got our own bounty gate going hashtag
Sean Payton let's play football great
again
and Henry Wilson say anybody pet and
Bitcoin on this game I recommend
depositing and withdrawing over my
bookie daddy G promo code TFT with
Bitcoin that's the best way to do
business with my bookie yeah I mean same
there's the same folks that are gonna be
playing with the lightsabers later they
don't know what BTC is important
important if you're gonna gamble in the
modern day show that you know a little
load update sea breeze under center
first and tenth taken over after that
pick six brutal they haven't ran the
ball yet and they do now and up to
latavius Murray I mean here's the thing
with these Saints games though lose one
they turn it on at some point they turn
it on and becomes like goddammit
Kendricks is player of the game so far
who know Captain Obvious was sitting
down eNOS tonight John I was gonna do a
call back to him what more are talking
about what he did with them switching
you know my bad back to our interview
with Jim Mora jr. check that out over in
sport scaling podcast.com play-action
he's having himself a game and if you
haven't watched these Madden Sims
there's a frustrating amount of bubble
screens that they run in this game we
have not figured out why but I will say
this if you're a Vikings fan or say
you're a guy in the Kramer gang who has
two units on plus six and a half this is
the exact start you want to see they're
hustling to the ball they're gang
tackling and most importantly the Saints
team not the shits on third and 12 deep
ball
[Applause]
Wow he's no sim guy does he get three
drops essentially and they've thrown it
to him three times zero completions
Henry Wilson checking in saying put
Taysom Hill in I agree I agree Jeff
Blake degrees did liked a some home I
was briefed for the for people who know
Jeff Blake is check out that this is not
a household name I went to a Pro Bowl
you know he's a bangle that's something
who day and we're watching who dat
they're down seven here in the
mercedes-benz Superdome still 11 minutes
left to go in the first plenty of time
to get involved in the live waging over
my book identity promo code t ft 1st and
10 from the 20 by the way Kirk Cousins
taking over out of the shotgun I'll say
it after this play Kirk back to throw
checks it down to Dalvin cook Captain
Kirk he could throw a pick six Sean oh
he's got that capability for sure and
I'm like the TBT no teams in the TFT
have tested positive for Kovac no all
completely clean not even Mike Zimmer
Zhai
Sean Payton of course did have Kovan
early on yeah beat it but a wintergreen
Skoal apparently that piers Cove 819 but
this is a battle of two coaches who love
dipping cook complete another completion
to cook so you took his receptions
that's looking good the player Pratt and
only four yards receiving on two catches
second and six and if you look in you
know something to watch on the defensive
side of the balls camp Jordan cam Jordan
is a nice one-man wrecking ball and if I
recall
the Vikings don't have the best
situation on the offensive line cousins
with the hard count third and six and
here he comes
but he gets it off again to Dalvin cook
home I don't really like a wide
receivers route right there you know it
means just that come back and honestly
part of the reason and you should tune
in and check out the rest of the top ten
list but part of the reason I put him at
number five yeah my top 10 running back
for this fantasy season Sean I don't
think had him in the dough and it was it
was all good and has a long full gut gut
take their first and 10 I'm a simulate
Bell is number one right yes first and
ten out of the 33 deep dangers thrown to
the outside by cousins
shout out to suited Joker over on Twitch
I know the but the Vikings scored on a
pick six that's how this game got
started this is their first offensive
possession Henry Wilson same big game
Kirk Cousins own bro he never loses in
prime time Henry I got a I got a back
her cousins in primetime for the next
hour and a half please cousins out of
the shotgun second and ten
checks it down under is y dope the
deepest strands and they they had their
moments the Saints defense it has goes
up and down sharp at the completion but
they can get hot much like the offense
they can score quick and the defense
really can turn it on at times get you
that quick turnover get you this quick
three and outs if Howard gets in sorry
Kim Jordan can it can get some pressure
he can really change his life that
matchup he's winning every time he
really is and they get they complete it
again to sharp nothing there though
Hart's agent and Cousins has five
completions for 28 yards is they got
he's got to throw the ball in a second
because camp Jordan is right like watch
just just watch that part of the game
he's swim moving and he's throwing the
lineman down every time but he's getting
at he's getting rid of the ball but but
it's gonna be a fumble it's gonna be a
defensive touchdown about Cousins under
center second and 10 from their own 48
bubble screen again
look at that again this is why it's so
frustrating that Sims at times
Justin Jefferson the rookie from LSU
loses to third and 12 and shout out to
Formula One Sean some live sport back
he's watching the Austrian Grand Prix
well in the Pilbara huge fan of the
Formula One cousins out of the shotgun
third and 12 big third down here has
some time down into New Orleans Saints
territory just trash and Shawn imagine
having a receiver with that kind of
speed is that Justin Jefferson there
that is it who isn't an anti-semite that
would be a big big upgrade for the
Eagles well you're alluding to DeSean
Jackson and listen it's a it's a
learning experience for the Sean you
want see how Berkley isn't he awoke the
smart guy okay just learning that Hitler
was bad hey we all know DeSean Jackson's
education process he's gonna meet with a
rabbi and learn that apparently Hitler
wasn't a good dude so I'm all for
learning and education to yard pickup
second and eight you know but he was a
great public speaker cousins high
formation some of his paintings weren't
bad and people say oh that's a what are
you trying to say he's got a little bit
of shoulder his defensive they're
gonna get a snap here call me down seven
and we're laying six and a half not a
good spot to be it's like being like the
guy was like you know that shows that
Applebee's aren't bad really polishing a
turd Erica on YouTube ATC checking in
st. in know Mike zippered Mike Zimmer
dipped Big Pig
he's a man now then cook out of the
shotgun over there right tackle by your
boy anals and Shawn have you have you
placed the one an anal zone I mean he
gets anything anything comes near the
anal zone it's getting sucked up Shawn
have you played the Kurt cousins drop
yet yes I did both of them I I don't
know if I have the hut hut but I do I've
played this one the hospital I love that
job we do love it second and 11 bubble
screen to Adam feelin it they run the
Vikings run a crazy amount of atmosphere
which is really good with cam Jordan
breathing down his throat but Jesus
Christ do you mean he he'll say and say
what you want about Mussolini but the
trains ran on time man made a hell of a
pasta Rudy Guiliani cousins out of the
shotgun big third down here her cousins
we doubted him what has happened to him
touchdown Adam feeling and there they're
feeling it right now
Saints about to go down 14 points at
home I'll be honest though I'm still not
worried how's the hash tag relax I don't
know buddy this defense looks like
man you didn't call me pic Tandy you
know well I assumed you wouldn't be on
my side so I wasn't I was fine jinxing
you call me Kirk is not he's fired up my
the Kramer game player problem over 268
that's great right now assuming they
don't just call off the attack because
they're dominating God look at those
locks on anals own well and Kramer I'd
love to know what the live total is
gonna be at because I think there's
gonna be value on the oh wait this this
Saints team is gonna put up some points
waiting for a nice gap here but the live
line is Saints plus three and it plus
two and a half minus 105 on the money
56 is the total again over at my bookie
dot AG use that promo code TFT I mean
it's your point 11 minutes ago in the
sim game the spread was saints -
six-and-a-half yes
14 points have happened but we still
have a lot of game into Shawn's point
you're gonna see the Saints team turning
on at some point hopefully not but they
usually do that their offense will will
score quick have we ever seen the Saints
lose yes yes we've lost one game it goes
to the Packers Daniel checking in on the
YouTube ATC what do the sgp boys think
the redskins should change their name to
the DC redmond i think that has a nice
ring to it
I mean I like his music what about
defenders DC don't know the Red Tails
actually was the best of the ones I'm
gonna go ahead senator red skin potatoes
they're young potato in the helmet
Kamara with the first carry of the game
only picks up two so the under so far on
Kamara rushing yards that's looking
pretty solid warriors is terrible
because warriors is in every other sport
how about warpath war the warpath /
warriors warpath doesn't but it's on the
song though you know it again bringing
tails sounds cool know where tails is
hold the Hogs like that's that's the way
to go I'm just so sick wow that's
warriors
since she just come the Redskins potato
on the helmet look I'm an Irish guy yeah
the sweet potatoes yeah Thomas with the
catch there first down and this is what
Brees it can do with the soffits like
they can just complete down the field
easily pick up first downs quickly and
often I mean seriously though while
we're at it we should probably rename
the Staples Center that you're telling
me the arena and the in the greatest
city in the country named after a
company that's out of business
wait how is how Staples still around
there was like a 20 year deal TRACON
Smith the catch picks up eight second
and two and this is that Saints team
getting hot look out Cramer the junior
they come the generals would be a good
name shout out to will Mormon over on
Twitter well that was the name of bull
they are their professional losers like
the Washington Generals or I mean what
was it was that the team that always
played yeah the generals were a team no
but who was the team that played the
Harlem Globetrotters it was the generals
right no I don't think so
I think you're thinking of something
else yeah who was the team that always
played the globe John Wyden someone
should know this they never beat him
right the generals yeah it's been a long
time since I saw the Globetrotters
exactly and that would fit the
Washington team I'm up to speed off the
Kimora nothing man damn it what are you
doing son third and three you gotta
throw the ball come on
they did an update dude they made drew
drew brees shitty they did it got you
guys act like Kirk Cousins isn't gonna
be good for a fumble return or a pick
six still I expect the sim guys that go
for it here to be throwing the ball up
at that sign tells you exactly what's
gonna happen it's always wrong the
offense was not at work I think it's
someone pointed out it's one play behind
punting has gotten better all the latest
updates
viii jimmy he'll say in three touchdowns
would be hard to come back from not in
the sim world it trust me this Saints
team can get out and Sean I want you to
guess the spring first could be due for
a turnover I'm gonna say that the people
over at my bookie know their stuff I'm
gonna say they still have saints favored
somehow like minus one plus three and
now plus three and a part is that the
whole thing most likely Matt looks like
Ben the Enzo shut up stop come on
after the distance to the goal of first
in fourteen now from their own for
totals 57 the generals won twice
according to Craig in unn
a TC YouTube it's a good deep that's one
nice pull feel like once is more
belittling twice it's like weird
once is like a good novelty split I cuz
ins under center first and 14 from the
floor hand it off to Dalvin cook not
much there picks up a couple out to the
eighth turnover loading second and ten
let's go baby
Nick 2480 saying mush Dundee can lose
more bets than John Elway Wow
shots fired I mean I don't really care
about that one I'm not a fan so it's
like hey you're an ly pen buzzing second
and ten out of the shotgun clock ticking
away here in the first steps up gets it
off to Dalvin cook cookies a big monster
fantasy day he really is slated in DFS
you're feeling great right now
like seven catches in the first quarter
we need some DFS on this that would be
the next step
Saints get a stop here this is huge
because they'll end up getting good
field position big third down here third
and four from the 14 cousins out of the
shotgun survey in the field they drop
the screen
and a great tackle that's a huge buy
five catches he 14 yards just a PPR
machine and Shawn that the guide the
live number of my bookie dot AG promo
code TFT that's where you can bet on
this game live wagering all game long
Saints are plus two and a half this is a
really funny cuz two and a half this guy
and the YouTube ATC hey Siri says his
first message is I'm confused what's
going on here one message later how do I
bet now welcome to the community bro
you're amongst friends this is a safe
place you head over to my bookie AG use
that promo code TFT deposit some BTC and
take the Saints and get loose we're
gonna be calling the next game two
Seahawks at Eagles Dan H sayin Red
Wolves gonna be fire next year I don't
mind Red Wolves s and that's trash
breeze back to throw checks it down
underneath the kamara nice room to run
done summer than the bender within the
nor into Minnesota territory and that's
where I thought he would do his damage
in the passing game okay cook the head
zero catches the first quarter head yeah
I told you to take that under they
didn't update in this game so told you
to take that I was I was just scared to
mess with Jared cook I was I was scared
to tempt fate braise heating up he's got
the red X how does he have the red s cuz
he's awesome seven for 12 with a pick
first and 10 and could have been like
pigs you know what Thomas - dammit
Michael Thomas with the grab they've
also got to get her at catching a chip
balls like that if you like
before earlier on when we're doing these
simulations they weren't catching tip
balls and now they are it's the little
ving Shawn they still they can't
get franchise mode right though these
losers over at EA don't don't
trigger the audience Kramer any idea and
cook rushing yards
we'll try Komara for carries for rushing
yards I mean I feel like you can almost
catch that now the the total that I said
go under a seventy seven and a half
Anthony bar Jesus Christ
another UCLA guy hey he's an
train outside with the Jets he was close
to sign with the Jets went back to the
Vikings I don't like him all right
breeze out of the shotgun third and
seven from the 42 big third down and a
great bullet pass to Michael Thomas
having him safely yeah you guys didn't
tell me that the game change you know we
had an update they don't cook at zero
catches this guy's got funnier I warned
you that when I tried to do this tactic
with Edelman it lost it was the same
thing because that only never caught the
ball cook was getting 70 targets a game
why weeks ago it's early
Kobe relax it's a long football game
first you ten hand it off to Kamara
again nothing they are on the running
game and most importantly your player
props are fire for fading so the fans
have clearly are gonna appreciate it
they want to know what you're gonna be
on for the next game I'm sure Daniel
saying the Washington Epstein's has a
nice ring to it well it does unlike
Epstein the Washington team often kills
itself so wool
self-inflicted wounds which didn't have
Nev seen obviously freeze out of the
shotgun blast I was just about to say we
haven't seen a Harrison Smith hit he's
like Bobby Wagner count as a catch right
oh my I think it does go down it this
Vikings team is he's higher right now
Kirk out of the shotgun and down here we
go
all we were doing is touting how people
needed to put the Saints high up in
their confidence pool and here we are
with 10 minutes to go in the second
quarter the Saints looking down the
barrel of a 14 Oh home deficit still
plenty of time but Jesus this bad Reggie
checking in is this a computer game yes
the computer is playing itself that's
cool that you gotta ask but you can bet
on it over at my bookie dad AG promo
code TFT down and cook not much there
for whoever was asking earlier only 18
yards for cooked so the under looking
pretty solid so far third and 11 and as
bad as things have been for the Saints
team two turnovers 156 they get the ball
back and get a score before half-time
the right back in it's fabulous cousins
out of the shotgun everything going
right for the Vikings right now get
there get there and they bring and they
bring pressure expect to the kid who
just runs right into
I mean the ad space nothing there fourth
and 12 nice three and had good recovery
for the Saints my passing prop is
starting to I'm starting to get a little
worried hunter saying the Vikings are
the better team well not in the
certainly not in Madden and they did go
down in New Orleans and Wayne in the
playoffs I was gonna say what's that
comment based well I mean they they did
go into New Orleans and win but I mean
if you've watched these Madden Sims New
Orleans is pretty dominant so I mean I'm
obviously I agree I'm on the Vikings
I bet the I bet the Vikings two units
the Kramer gang we're riding heavy
against the Greenies right now Sports
speaks and great show guys thumbs up
appreciate it shoutout Reggie saying I
first thought it was a real game a nice
that's you guys we're talking about it's
a great commentary thank you and
subscribe to the sports gaming podcast I
think you'll enjoy that as well freeze
under center pullback in motion
first and ten hands it off to latavius
Murray spin move mr. garrison Smith he
might be the honorary Bobby Wagner who
we're gonna get to see in the next game
that guy is he straight fire he's just a
fumble record this ground game hasn't
been working but I understand you got to
go to something else because the pass
game where is Jared Cook he's on a
milk carton somewhere Sean I
love this Kobe's mush powers on the
brush breeze play action on second of
five has all day in the sim God Oh
Jesus Christ can we do it Cheers we
didn't do it Cheers we should do it
cheers Wow Oh done Dino Cheers
that you know what Shawn I'm gonna get
really hammered today yeah Wow for your
own sake I do hope Eagles do well later
cook with the hand off anal zone on the
tackle this is a crazy swing we've never
shown this out of the sink let me throw
something out I think we were in Vegas
Vikings Falcons do you member how the
Vikings got up so early that Kirk
Cousins only had to throw the ball like
ten times yep I feel like we're watching
that game right there about to go up 21
nothing and he's only had to throw the
ball I think 10 times maybe 11 times
we're gonna hold him to three and he
salutes the troops that's what I'm
talking about we love America here on
the sports gambling podcast that was
wrong yes hey is that cam Jordan in
coverage well hunter Stokes shouting he
looks like he's right saying the Vikings
are the better team Jon let's get
kicking their ass let's get out a $50
free play you you you call it I'm
calling it $50 telling people how to
enter okay all you gotta do is head over
to the sports gambling podcast podcast
the Apple podcast right give a review
saying like hey we enjoy the Madden
whatever it is send in a screenshot of
you giving us a five star review tweet
it out at CamLAN podcasts on twitter at
CamLAN podcast screenshot of your five
star review best one will give a $50
free play at my bookie dot AG at for the
fifty not fit five zero 50 for the
podcast while you listen to the podcast
and this is a podcast you're listening
to now oh wow 13% let me guess you're
voting for Kanye yes of course I mean no
none of these guys got heat on their
beats you know what I mean and we got to
give a shout out of course to superfan
Bo vice
we may have miss you in the chat
apologies you know number one fan he's
the guy who gave us that awesome drop
and of course this awesome drop as well
[Applause]
mumbo vise he showed us some amazing
meat product July 4s what's the live
line oh no cold I'm gonna go in Colby's
down go in this breeze under center
first and ten from the 22 Saints plus 7
plus 165 on the money line alright
they can't run it you know what it is
Shawn they can't get any going front
seven is devastates have so much trouble
dealing with a front seven and then when
you introduce Harrison Barnes on the
back end Mike Zimmer DB's physical
strong guys I mean we've always liked
Mike Zimmer I can't believe you went
against them here with the cheaters from
New Orleans it's gotta go up percent a
second ten bullet pass complete doesn't
kind of the catch for for them you're
done Emmanuel Sanders it does call me
come on I'm just making sure you never
know it's a video game you're in bit you
know come on dude who can we talk about
here's a catch we have Manny fumbled it
and then Thomas recovered it I call them
Harrison Barnes by the way Harrison
Schmitt this Vikings defense is insane
Harrison Smith is money right now he
really is breeze out of the shotgun deep
ball on the outside knee comes limits
this and again throwing it to this piece
of Jason you would be really
surprised to know that Colby has money
on the Saints sketches over/under seven
no no what I'm getting is as bad as it
seems for the Saints team they can score
trust me they can score hell yeah they
can score let's go another number of
fumble Oh bubble screen Emmanuel Sanders
dangerous shot here's what I'll say now
while I've watched many we've seen
probably one seven eight nine Saints
games most of the time they just turned
it on but I will say that they're
turning it on and then since Smith's
coming over no thank you ain't up the
trash yeah look at all the stars on the
field right now The X Factor's they got
a ton of them Brees heating up again
maybe you won't throw a goddamn
interception second and 11 and now let's
score a touchdown this time guys instead
of a back-breaking turnover a pick six
he's was beating this thing Mick 2480
why did I think that Michael Tom Thomas
wouldn't get targets because we've
caught about 300 of these games and
normally Jared Cook gets all the targets
it I will say there has been a shift
away from the tight end in general in
that notice in all these games it seems
like Brees out of the shotgun completes
it to Sanders lucky there was an
imbalance I don't know yeah they're
giving it to him second and six boy was
he running away for him from his life
but Harrison Smith was just knocking him
down
didn't look like you got to down there I
want to cook it what's his Nick does he
have a nickname Harrison Smith we just
start calling the Raptor a lot sure
Murray's under center second and six at
the 14 Thomas the lone back I'm sorry
Kamara
don't go towards Harris and Smith
completes it to the outside that Jerry
is the only picks up two yards third and
four I mean it's easy to see a tight
turn I feel like the first game of
madden mayhem Jared Cook had likes 15
catches that's what I'm saying dude
there was plenty of games where he had
like 10 12 catches field goal here would
be huge you've changed man
you shaved yeah it seems like
they're going away from the tight end
these sins
breeze out of the shotgun on third and
four get into the end zone
come on are you doing cuts it down
underneath Jack what are you doing
run the round past the sticks god damn
that would not be happy right now I
gotta go for this room and is rolling
over in his grave
[Applause]
Wow I mean what's the what's the live
getting lying gonna be if they don't get
a touchdown here
Kramer we're being told it's Harry the
Hitman Smith that's a pretty badass name
that's way better than the Raptor Harry
the Hitman Smith watch why are you
kicking a field goal here just
losers I quit
because they didn't want to it's a
mental win they got on them they got
points on the board Shawn and Vikings
we'll start with the ball in the second
half I know I was just point that out
they do get the ball for Harry the hit
man shout out to Jeff Stan over on
YouTube that's why is it Harry the hit
man he's put he's putting people of body
bags out there like Harry Harrison okay
okay Perry Smith I guess so I mean yeah
I mean what else you'd call a guy named
Harrison it's kind of a weird name no
offense of the name Harrison but it's a
lot to say I'm Harrison Ford because he
crashes airplanes every alright so you
crash into defense this is how much you
know the book knows that the Saints are
coming back it's still plus seven and a
half Wow Plus no wait hold on we have an
update the money line has just jumped to
plus three thirty for the Saints that
may be this is when you buy Colby get on
that marking down back 2 plus 175 plus
7.5 is the spread 56 is the total I
don't know that the Vikings there's
about for the Vikings right now yeah and
remember it just send in a screenshot of
your five-star review of the sports
gambling podcast and you know we'll hook
you up $50 free plug bookie free play to
the best five star review tweeted
sending the screenshot tweeted out at
gambling podcast Dylan Gould checking in
on Twitter saying Vikings are no joke
enough that they hate cousins out of the
shotgun first and ten dicks loading
dangerous throw incomplete trying to
force it to down the cook once again he
has like six catches and then maybe nine
targets is insane he's only thrown like
14 balls shout out to Nick over on
Twitch Marvin Harrison is rolling over
in his grave that his nickname wasn't
Harry the Hitman little on the nose
there for a guy who actually murdered
people Google that cousins out of the
shotgun second and ten let's go is he
showing everyone how big is that what
dance was that that's the a mechanic on
a bansuri dude look at he's doing
the Anderson Cooper man I knew it was
coming hopefully that's the last one but
Jesus and rare I mean what were the odds
that the Saints defense went out score
the offense in the first half we're
seeing a wild game but this is why these
games are exciting this is why I'm gonna
bet on them to your yes three timeouts
we can get the ball back in 2117
halftime show that's what I'm open for
it you of course are watching the
football tournament sports gambling
podcast my bookie Todd Agee and ATC aka
all things comedy this is really
disappointing sure know what whether we
got an interesting exciting game every
one of these games ends up being good
whenever we simulate these things they
end up getting buck wild and of course
still time to get in on that $50 free
play just tweet in the screenshot of
your five star review send it in to act
game-like podcast did I did say I did
say $50 yes
fifty smackers alright we got we got a
winner oh do we yes
and it's as luck would have it the guy's
name is Harry Smith no 34 34 7 literally
just made this Twitter account to show
my guys at game when podcast some love
there we go Ben
on them on my bookie for a while love
these guys Congrats
every one of our fans signs up for
Twitter to send us a message like the
dijon's live in dark places away from
the internet all right let's go Kurt
come on cousins remember what do you
when he missed the the gender-reveal
yeah he missed the target cousins back
to throw first and ten check sit down
with me Mike I'll word Captain Kirk aka
captain check down see I knew I should
have taken the touchdowns I got scared
off by the juice on the cousins
touchdown prob now I got a sweat this
yardage thing out I would already be in
the bag it was over one and a half oh
hold on wait they were call we gained
some weight yeah
cooked with the hand off there picks up
a couple two-minute warning Vikings got
a first down first in 10 you fellas need
a bill Berta guest commentator well he's
in studios right here check it go
showing checking in on he's in the VIP
lounge in the homes
mahomes big contract first in ten two
minute warning three timeouts for the
Vikings first and ten from their own 39
no sack let's check the throat checks it
down underneath getting the tight end
going fumble and this is what they
needed to answer here they need it to at
least cross midfield eat some clock make
sure the Saints won't have time to score
that field goal if the Vikings can get
three before half I'll be more than
happy going it's up to touchdowns they
get the ball in the second half eat the
rest of this clock let's go not gonna
happen
let's go to the shotgun first and ten
back to throw checks it down to Rudolph
again and
I'm glad I your welcome Sean I thank you
you can be a man and thank me I did I'm
saying thank you that was a great call I
was I was ready to take under Kirk or
under Cal Rudolph but he's my first half
he went up here and we reminded you he's
a he's a alumni of Notre Dame so that's
something you like same with Harrison
Smith right cousins out of the shotgun
she's wide open Dalvin cook yes it's
just like watching this is like playing
a little kid who figured out that the
angle route works really well in that
they're just running that with the tight
end or Dalvin cook every time and keep
sending those five star reviews in we
will pick another winner here next
touchdown mmm or injury shout out to
Magic Man Blancos that had to drop that
five-star review for pick Tandy in the
college experience really appreciate
that pick dundies breaking down all 130
college football teams one episode at a
time make sure you find the college
experience wherever great podcasts are
heard cousins out of the shotgun
completes it to cook once again so that
the new thing the new thing is to throw
it to the running back to this game
because series got 20 catches III told
you he could have a good game I told you
he's my number 5 a weird stat line 8 for
29 all right just call me we can't let
him score touchdown here and have they
fixed the clock manager we because this
could be perfect there there are times
where these the sims have no idea what
they're doing when it comes to the clock
at the end of the half Oh dangerous
throw I mean he had a guy open there
could have put it in the end zone
just bad throw like her cousins we need
a run here in the different
last time out Sean yeah that would be
great a sack wasted time out and then
one more sack to bleed the clock out
that would be ideal
come on here we go
cousins out of the shotgun second and
ten another incomplete pass
shout out to Nick 2480 says he's you
love and his team by team breakdowns
just finished the Florida State one go
Seminoles and po vise check him in the
my bookie Madden twitch page did you see
my meets yes we saw your meets beau they
were amazing your meats were great bro
it was great he goes woohoo smoking my
meats and show us speaking of meat
shoutout to the brats stop yes
he's got dealing right he's going that
completely Kirk look at this dancing oh
my god was that Kirk has thrown now four
touchdowns in the first half three three
two Minnesota one two new who is that
it's a sharp Taj a sharp with the touch
early because the nose herb Smith jr.
was it is it smell or is there Smith jr.
I noticed I see a sharp now that's what
I initially thought but the number was
off people will tell us people like to
correct us it's one of those things the
Internet does well guys shout out to the
to the Minnesota Vikings with Chad Beebe
yeah shut up Don Beebe go home look at
you Don Beebe did come on the show
sports gambling podcast long time
Buffalo Bill and Green Bay Packers what
do you do like five Super Bowls in like
seven years or something something like
that crazy streak six honey
who the are we great question Kahn
the YouTube ATC chat room where the
sports gambling podcast i'm shawn
sagging the money green with my partner
Ryan real money Cramer and of course
joined by Colby dant aka the dancer bass
aka pick Dundee if I'm that's me then
who the hell am I Jesus Christ you're so
you're so meta you're just all Madison
it I see it
musta had a good good night last night
well I got the Colombian livin in the
house right now
oh no so we're gonna we're gonna throw
out another a $50 free play
I mean if you want to let's do it still
chance if you already sent one in that
one's still active but still time
sending a screenshot of a five-star
review of the sports gambling podcast
tweet at us at gambling podcast so we
got you taken care of and yeah best oh
one will get a $50 free play for my book
daddy 100 code TFT 2810 we can get a
touchdown here right timeouts 41 seconds
Cramer debt I mean when it's 40 nothing
I was saying take the is that
take the oh here we go 4 yard pass and
burn time man John can we start playing
the drone strike anytime Harry the hit
man shows up dude is just fire
all right Saints plus 10 and 1/2 plus 2
10 on the money line Shawn Dan Haley Sam
what's up man is this the new man
no it's the older Madden but it's with
updated rosters so yeah it's mad 92
can't you see so Stefon Diggs is not on
the Vikings it's probably the only big
and then we have the rookie class in
there as well but it is Madden 29 men 21
Steve wash with that pass third and 10
now for the Saints and they're letting
the clock run Vikings are happy up its
gonna run it out here Wow this raisi
team go C team great news for over
bettors of 38 points in the first half
Wow imagine being a Saints fan oh
they're great what were they doing just
a fumble losers they ran the clock out
Sean and what's his name oh crap I mean
they're gonna riot yeah why why are
there some people cheering what the hell
is going on Wow what all right so too
many grenades grenades I mean just no
matter what here's the crazy part
I see the Saints have more total offense
Sean and they were their offense has
been driving the ball pretty easily is
it just they've been 186 throw-in yards
is it just the turnovers turnovers as a
regression will be do well I mean three
interceptions for Brees Saints have more
time opposed or two interceptions and
that fumble they have more time a
possession they have more yards things
are gonna go the Saints way in the
second half will it be enough to win
and/or cover that they're gonna need
can't turn the ball over three times
Sean no hey Kramer Hellerman wants to
know where you can find the seedings to
this tournament you can just go to
sports gambling podcast.com slash ATC or
you can just be aware of what happened
in the playoffs last year AFC already
happened and not surprisingly bills
found a way to lose against the Texans
the Titans upset the Patriots dead
yeah it's so funny I mean we did it as
like a redo of the 2019 playoffs and
it's been it's been happening to the
team bills were up huge in the first
half they blew that lead Cam Newton for
the Patriots through ignore basically a
game ending interceptions much like
Brady devastating cousins more than
halfway to my over passing yards he's
already over his his passing touchdown
Sean that was mine that was one and a
half that was easy money I don't know
what drew brees his number was but he's
got 186 cut quietly because it doesn't
feel like yeah there's like 280 he's a
piece of right nothing in the
rushing Kamara kimura the under rushing
yards prop I gave out I mean that feels
greatest nothing no way he gets 68
rushing yards in the second half that
feels awesome here's where people are in
trouble the colbys of the world doesn't
hit it if you're not aware
Colby's record on player props now is 0
for whatever he's bet yeah so yeah
whatever he's doing next game I would
fade it but what did you take your
Thomas under seven and a half I did
Thomas is already over his passing
yardage prop everyone else is is
trending under except for maybe Kyle
Rudolph Jones you're welcome his on pace
for 16 catches and it was herb Smith jr.
for the record who has two touchdowns
and we have another winner of the $50 my
bookie free play shout to Max Milano on
Twitter his review oh wow maybe this I
don't know if this review will actually
get through but I want a reward and
regardless the review title is anal zone
bro these dudes hilarious I want my free
play they call Alex and zall own anal
zone bro WTF I mean look at him doesn't
he look like an a on his pictures on the
screen i i pronounced that anal zone i
don't know how you pronounce that he
went to florida probably was there one
team I was there oh I'm sorry is my dick
dyslexia a problem for you I'm
sorry I'm sorry it's offensive to me
that you're offended by my
mispronunciation of anal zone all right
Maria what are we looking in the second
half Kramer shout-out to Lutz
can we see can we see where we're at
as far as second half lines of action
weekend denote the number of course as
Shawn's been saying repeatedly yeah over
to my book EDG get involved live action
just like day trading it's fun for all
the second half number Vikings it +7 so
a game adjusted is gonna be Vikings plus
11 Saints Saints or I'm sorry Vikings
minus 11 Saints plus 11 so you gotta lay
seven for the Saints in the second half
the total is 27 so you're saying I'm
gonna get an adjusted game line of
Saints plus 11 you can get so bad yes
please let's write it all day with that
I mean I'm getting that all back the
team total Vikings ten and a half Saints
seventeen Sean are you also you double
dip and you go in total as well cuz they
got what was the team total 17 if you
think they're winning the game yes they
got a score at least 17 all right we got
a yeah and then you have score first
Saints are slight favourites to score
first even though the Vikings start with
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't touch that I
mean I mean maybe there's value on on
Vikings score first but score last I
mean my bookie Madden pointing out in
the twitch chat maybe a second half
onside kick ooh the start I don't I mean
we saw it before we've seen this we've
seen yesterday second half we've seen
sharp rise the surprise onside kick my
CPU isn't known that processor unless
you can use it on that processor
kool-aid loves that hey the more on
Arnold quotes the better you know life's
better with the I he said my family
eating my birthday cake on my birthday
Colby's just heads heads deep in the
impressions that all right anything else
you want to see Oh Ethan Harley saying
tell these guys to give me a job intern
job well well if you think you have what
it takes for to work for sgp n drop us a
line podcast at sports gaming podcast
calm
Podcast at sports gambling podcast.com
what's your opinion on Tom Brady and Joe
that's the first question it's the first
interview question yes you answer that
wrong you're out the door we're no
longer hiring people that think Genoa is
better than we already have one that's
enough yeah it's a trick question
those guys q cross 7-eleven Saints
Saints - seven or Saints team total over
a 17 which one do you like so you got to
pick one Shawn yeah if you had to pick
an investment strategy are you looking
for the back door through the the plus
11 or are you just gonna go with a
straight vol 17 you I got to imagine if
you think the Saints are gonna get back
to this game and cover the plus 11 you
kind of think they're scoring 17 points
right isn't that the safer bet yeah if I
was advising the Kramer gang do
something stupid and inside and bet on
the same side as the green easing and in
the pic Dundee and the chin is saying
now seven and a half so I would with
that movement I'm saying take the over
17 the dance a maniacs and whatever we
call them at the end of the day you
gotta you gotta be smart here and I'd go
17 over the spread I'll be honest yes
okay Saint total 17 now that especially
that's moved to seven and a half but
well go for a go for hoops trying to
challenge me in golf I mean look I don't
want to speak for my game although the
last two rounds I was I've been hitting
straight bombs
Shawn can vouch for he was there for 18
of the holes I mean you guys are out
golfing cuz we're gonna need that when
when we go to Hawaii and hang out with
June Jones and all and I'll just be the
guy sipping margaritas I'll just I'll
carry the team but yeah anyway go for
hoops over on Twitch look into looking
to do a little wagering on the golf game
look I will be I will happily bet anyone
golf if they're paying for the golf
putt-putt does that go for a miniature
girl sure I'm compared I'm a competitive
let's go
I was watching late night frisbee golf
I'm like ah this might be some bad
frisbee golf seems pretty cool those
dudes get throw really cool are you guys
talking about frolf
no I'm here's the thing there's nothing
worse than when you're on a par 3 that's
also a frisbee golf course and some
hippie walks by barefooted like
hey sorry bro it's like dude it's cool
like my golf balls gonna hurt way more
than your frisbee like that's how it's
gonna work out boy I didn't know that
they even did the double the double
thing you know what I mean I figured
they all just had to shout out to the
Bell in Burbank all right we ready to
start at 6 o'clock I'm feeling good
I think Skeletor 603 603 the official
timekeeper Shawn let's quickly talk
about the nightcap yeah NFC of course
wildcard weekend rerunning than 2019
playoffs the Seahawks head to Philly and
yes Carson Wentz is healthy is gonna be
playing at least is starting the game
the guys work in the YouTube all things
comedy who put Nate son felt in the
promo image which is a I don't know if
it was intentional or not that was just
an awesome troll trolling you
Seahawks - four and a half Wow
disrespectful no love for the the the
once led by Vince Papale a Philadelphia
Eagles - four and a half for the
Seahawks - 225 on the money line Eagles
plus 150 at home at home Shawn play that
DMX because hungry dogs run faster
you've told me that before 48 yeah half
is the total this field here's the thing
you're gonna take the Eagles I know you
are yes I get Bobby Wagner that means in
a single day I get two back Smith and
Bobby Wagner why and the Eagles aren't
as good in men as they are in real life
and you know I mean goddamn it but the
Seahawks do have Doug Peterson's number
and the Eagles so Shawn you got the odds
stacked against them but hey hungry dogs
all right ask your 603 I'm not sure what
that is but uh it's 603 Saints are
coming back it's 603 are we ready are
people over on Twitch ready people over
YouTube ready everyone got their second
half bets in yeah no one's racing to the
window trying to get that last minute
Jimmy in get that nose beer in before
it's too late
oh no you know we are fans of nose beers
we are fan of the milligrams as I told
you light night for me I'm only 25 deep
but I did I did pair it with 25 CBD so I
could I could render myself unconscious
here in the second half Shawn are you
ready I'm ready
she's not there dude you're all right
you nervous about the Eagles no I'm my
energy is amazing and nervous about the
Eagles Magic Man Blanco is asking about
the dog mask stay tuned that's all I'm
gonna say about that I'm not nervous
about the Eagles I was trying to help
facilitate some free play to the great
listeners of the sports gaming podcast
and like that free tournament presented
by my bookie daddy G promo code TFT come
on defense cousins under center first
and ten from the 25 handed off the
Dalvin cook come on who is that let's
burn some clock let's work it down the
field and let's let's go out there and
get that revenge Shawn we're all the
people that have said those things about
Kirk Cousins and his inability to be a
franchise quarterback
gotten paid he just needs to win ace
plays are checking in Shantanu ace
shoutout days blades Manning the drone
striking console Kirk Cousins hands it
off to Devin cook nothing there remember
to tip your waitstaff third and three
all right Jenkins let's do this again my
mistake
aces here every night working the drone
strike he's got a he just got tip your
weight step that's all I'm saying
huge third down here early in the third
quarter Cousins under center cook the
lone back get their hands and all you
get the right penetration talkative
bikes you know it anal zone anal zone
doing this
once you go anal zone it's tough to go
back highway 70 anal zone let's go all
right we'll stop by the Saints need that
how do you actually pronounce that a
Dulce okay I was just checking how do
you think you got his wife Vikings have
to punt on fourth and three he let her
go to the handle so that's different as
a gentleman I mean you know no quid pro
quo
hey where it's 2020 right very
progressive gentlemen whatever it takes
I feel you all right this is it
Cook has two catches what was that over
eight eight and a half I think that one
dude over on twitch wants to know where
we have a Dalvin rushing yards no one
has any rushing yards I think he's got
Dalvin is more than Kamara but even
that's like 20 it's not good breeze out
of the shotgun out the play actually
good block by deep down there we middle
the trick once Smith that was a chop
block a great block love a good chop the
pain he's not engaged with another
defender that's a legal block you see
how fast he went down when Harry was
coming to breathe in down look at this
look at Harry Harry's coming down he
goes down oh he's the hit man that's a
badass nicked in Brees out of the
shotgun first and ten already the red X
let's do it Joe Wow in the Vikings
territory early here in the third
[Applause]
I'm telling you I've caught conspiracy
he said those things about he'll stand
for the national anthem they went in
they hacked into the main floor
them up the red X is supposed to
mean that they're heating up and maybe
it just meant he had a really bad hot
take about the American flag look-see
Philly too raw it's pronounced a Knowles
own yeah that's how it yeah you're
welcome I got it right
don't try to get in my head Mickey Rogo
36 I lost but this is hilarious it I
mean you can't be that mad if it breeze
is gonna throw this many interceptions
and goddammit
Cousins completes it down to the what do
we got 12 yard line
Mikey another move here another thing is
these returns I mean even though he
didn't score this was like a 60 yard
return she broke the initial tackle that
was huge he got flipped the field and
now again Kirk Cousins yardage prop is
in trouble I think he's not gonna need
to throw the ball fourth quarter second
half the half cheers cousins out of the
shotgun first and ten
Oh from the 12 completes it underneath
the feeling picks up a handful I notice
I'm drinking out of these Virginia Tech
glass here welcome and I want to tell
you that my friends over at their
podcast Oh what good Sean green like
this free play didn't buy didn't plug
their podcast I just have my friends at
no podcast
told me to let me know what games we
want to go to it we can get tickets
Cramer they're taking a why they're
good tickets second floor hands off to
cook cam Jordan in there to clean things
up okay Jordan a little worse it's the
best for Jay if you're at Virginia Tech
alum and you're not listening to too
deep Hokies under the influence at best
BT podcast out there too deep in the
anal zone you know what Nate yeah that
was my sophomore year ready to transfer
majors cousins out of the shotgun
[Applause]
back to throw to the end zone come on go
subscribe
Captain Kirk said his phasers doing
complete there we got a message saying
he can't leave her review apparently
well he needs to get yeah he said I
don't have iTunes I said get iTunes what
do you what do you live what do you use
it go to an iPhone you don't have a
podcast app Vikings
field goals up in a student 110 you can
leave a review on stitcher
Alex Cunningham go Birds hell yeah Alex
Cunningham fly you know come on up he's
the guy that well maybe we give this guy
the free play anyway he's an Eagles fan
that's different I didn't realize that
sir you should have led with that so how
many yards the Sud field throw for in
this game hopefully Jalen Hurd's gets
into that would just be icing on the
cake
alright here we go down 21 Cramer what's
the live number at I'm waiting for it to
surface here maybe it's just my computer
but man this is I never in a million
years would have pictured a game going
this way Saints plus thirteen and a half
still feels too small
I was 350 Sean maybe that's the lute
that's the buyback angle 65 is the total
saints 38 Vikings 31 on the shot let's
go baby
over time loading that's what I'm
talking I poked or says this game is
fake as yeah it's not real this is
not a real football game this is in the
virtual world it's real there i poker
are you watching the game with dick
Gertz burger Saints will take over on
their own 24 I mean can't it Brees
throws another interception we just got
a he's got to get that birthmark truly
removed you know to me like it's toys
under Center first and ten from the 24
hands off to Kamara nothing there but
also he's married his use this seed a
number of times what what seats what's
who give who does he
they should just bring it yes true and
he's in New Orleans everyone's all
up you know what I mean like it's
a character it's a defining attribute of
his face even if you wanted to go out
and get a snow breeze out of the shotgun
second a9 from the 26
yeah Harrison Smith's about to hard
count hands it off to Kamara finds a
little bit of the scene
I took the X to New Orleans and we're
like checking into the Hilton there no
and as we're checking in a couple in
their 50s or 60s walks in from Bourbon
Street and they're arguing mmm and
they're in a heated argument and the guy
vomits eat your freeze
under center third and three pitch out
to Kamara gets to the outside what are
you doing why you're horrific it ruining
the ball goddamn it I'm just gonna drink
bourbon they're running on their loss
they're running out of time people are
asking about the free play I announced
the two winners I've DM them on Twitter
from at gambling podcast max Milano and
Bill at Harry Smith 34 3 4 7 so perfect
punt hunts it into the end zone
this team and reminder Shawn we are
calling the next game that's gonna start
sometime around 7:00 p.m. on the East
Coast 10:00 p.m. elite or I'm sorry 7:00
p.m. on the west coast 10:00 p.m. on the
East Coast and it's gonna be your
Philadelphia Eagles hosting the Seattle
Seahawks oh you should stick around for
that
I will be sticking around well I know
you are you have no choice I'm not going
anywhere
now you can't leave anal zone is looking
really perky hands it off to me howling
hey who's that on the stop is that
Malcolm Jenkins it is let's settle it
flat let's settle it this team is not
playing for Drew Brees this team is not
playing for drew Brees yeah Jameis
Winston Sean let's go let's go out of
the hot take machine Jameis Winston is
starting for the Saints one game by week
12 this year
Taysom Hill by week 8 stop it Dalvin
cook the outside easily picks up the
first down throws down the defender what
you're telling me the lineman is not
gonna miss that block crag on the area
ATC saying can you put a prop bet down
as soon as Brees gets a hot X for an
interception
it does seem yeah every time he gets a
true yeah oh yeah yeah come on they're
showing blitz breeze or sorry a cousins
under center first and 10 from their own
37 hands enough to Dalvin cook not shoot
move slow roll that not much there EJ
edje on HTC YouTube saying wonder how
many grandmas have upon meeting briefs
lick their thumb and went after that
thing talking about the mole well there
is that there was that viral clip of
Oprah going oh when he comes out for the
interview she goes oh you got something
right on your cheek there Andy she tries
to wipe off the birth second innate
complete sad Adam feeling runs out of
bounds showing the first it's amazing
how much better the Vikings have looked
as a team and we thought when the Saints
had scored an offensive touchdown show
no this is insane I mean the Vikings
office hasn't done much because
everything has been easy you know had to
do much but we've seen so many teams not
convert in the red zone we've seen so
many teams not be able to get those
couple first downs to get a drive going
you know say what you will about cousins
I will say what I will see you Kirk
Cousins is getting it done right now
cook picks up a couple that's a first
down for the Vikings clock continues to
run first and 10 from the 47 what do we
all go further
best quarterback performance in the
football tournament so far Wow okay well
make us ins under center you did throw a
pick six yeah that's it one blow
no detectable time I'm backing off that
one Jordan rules the world says Kobe
sucks at these Madden Sims I wasn't
property yeah Kobe does suck picked on D
on the other hand hotter than a in Texas
shout out the deaf Stan over on YouTube
when's the army-navy rematch amen
I want actually we should switch it up
into air force mommy no army Navy's
better no no it's not a fumble if they
catch I'm over that's the problem
Justin Jefferson picks up zero third and
ten live number over at my boogie dot AG
yes you can bet on this yes there are
live wagering and that live number is
Saints plus 14 and a half plus 450 on
the money line 62 is the total Wow it's
becoming more and more real I've been
there before chase chase chase and all
of a sudden you just got to give up
cousins checks it down to cook gets
wrapped up to Jordans not as good as
known to us cooks injured someone just
got a free play right there's nothing we
were throwing at him and the Saints
cache it with a bounty oh wow Oh Matt
Madison he's a guy - look look - in
fantasy if you're gonna draft cook you
got a handcuffed him
what's all that buzz just yeah that's
hilarious he's like Odell pissing on the
field upside down and we got an injury
$25 free play up for grabs Kramer how
are we gonna award this to the great
people I think this one should just be a
what what what do we normally do
Twitter like send picture your setup
right yeah send a picture of you
watching the game whatever kind of setup
you got going whatever the record
doesn't have to be you in the picture
yes your setup you care to bless your
unless you're a lady if you're the one
lady out there you're one of your
picture female viewers yeah feel free to
throw yourself in the picture but yeah
we get it we're doing we're not we're
nothing we're nothing to look at either
and by the way did you see who's in
first place in the football tournament
wins pool Alyssa play list of plates
breeze there it is you gotta go - what's
a facemask you call that you filthy
animals Jared cook at the catch after
the 35 look and we got a touchdown
before this before this quarter so
you're right you are it's it's only a
three score game somehow it's only a
three score game and sending those
tweets of your setup at gambling podcast
for that $25 free play breeze under
center first and ten from the 35 bullet
pass with Thomas he dropped it and as
you trust I'm still alive Smith is alive
he's just a head hunter he just killing
Thank You Harry the headers
the filly too raw over on twitch blowing
up dudes left and right he sometimes
identifies as a woman look and if you
were watching over on the my bookie
twitch page make sure you head over to
twitch.tv slash sports gambling podcast
give us a following breathes under
Center hands it off to alvin kamara
picks up a handful Zimmer having the
eyepatch was one of the greatest moments
yeah in the past decade of NFL football
it's classic what do you do that for
like weeks - I feel like wasn't just one
game man like it was like three or four
weeks all right I mean all right
so the Kramer gang sitting pretty I need
a little bit more on the cousins passing
yarns put plus six and a half that's a
lot right chance a big it's gonna happen
it's a big crazy move on third and five
bullet deadly you know and here's some
Smith he was red - he's a red X and that
guy's ax he's a bad dude did you see the
video of Calvin kumara working out with
like a bar over his shoulders and
kettlebells no he's a beast part of the
reason why he he's pretty highly ranked
in my top 10 fantasy running backs Sean
you should check that out as he should
be over on the sports gambling podcast
breeze out of the shotgun first and ten
dangerous throw again to Emanuel Sanders
incomplete as if me or the Saints
receivers struggling they are in space
with these defensive backs coached by
Mike Zimmer maybe the best defensive
back coach in the history of the NFL ooh
bold take that's Mike Hughes who was
undefeated won a national championship
at UCF I mean he's no blood Foster but
he's pretty good what's going on here we
bleeding the clock down 21 you
Louie you really are they I think they
want to go home hands it off to Kamara
get to the outside just absolutely
filthy play not much there third and
eight and we got a we got a winner here
at it's a Cleveland fan at Cleveland
underscore TV he's got a he's got a nice
set up here three screens set up going
got a little Indians thing in the
background Congrats you want a $25
FreePlay Colby doesn't have the
major-league hat on did he complete some
Michael time and of course he fumbles
again it counts as a catch that hits the
over oh my god these player the game
he's got two guns that he immediately
bumbled dude how many turnovers is his
defense at I mean it started with
Kendricks it's finished with Smith
I mean so you want to talk about a no
overall impressive team effort I mean
this Fool has eight catches now and two
of them have been caught for a second
completely just folded like I mean these
guys are different mate difference
makers they every tackle they make is a
potential formal this is insane
five turnovers for the Saints cousins
out of the shotgun second and twelve
handed off to cook and this is just
hilarious it's so much like the 2019
playoffs they said this tournament has
been this is the backup shot so even in
spite of losing Pro arguably their most
dynamic offensive weapon now yeah Philly
to raw saying this is the worst day of
my life I love it no no exaggeration
answer cam George that's pressure
interception oh my god just threw that
up there you gotta go up and make a
play on the ball goddamn it
this is great
yeah this units full of ice saying dude
I'm gonna lose this over I know what the
wait well what do you have what what are
people sitting on throw your bets out in
the chat yeah if you're if you're in the
over gang with it's gotten there's only
been three points in the third quarter
we see this in the third quarter
sometimes yeah it's 48 points in the
first half they really got better at
hunting which affords up but three of
titans
the totals back down to 57 Sean I almost
want to take the over now they're gonna
heat up at some point Dalvin cooks
injury weekend week save questions plus
14 and a half plus 500 on the money line
57 is the total over at my bookie AG
promo code TF t get rid of it nice how
did he hang onto the ball you got hit by
Harrison I was gonna say the word socket
rash the worst thing that can happen to
a Saints offensive player is to break
through the linebacker level and get to
the secondary because then you're having
to deal with that he's taking heads
off hitman 2 confirmed kills already
person Shann Brees at the 37
14:23 left to go in the fourth back to
throw out of the shotgun completes it to
Michael Thomas monarch bride says the
Saints need Darren Sharper one of the
hardest hitting six it's a little harder
off the field shout I Asian jazz music
courses quoting that great viral video
about Greg Jennings rare
yeah do put the team on his back this
broke his leg how am i
doing format in second in one breeze
touch past Emanuel Sanders first damn
you know Shawn the game has changed
they've they've had no trouble
completing the ball no trouble getting
first downs racking up passing yards
they have no points the Saints offense
has no points for the first third
quarters I've never seen anything like
this and like they don't target cook
anymore
team is this I don't know this team
Saints as breeze out of the shotgun
empty set first and ten if I'm that's me
who the hell am I check sit down McKay
is speak of the devil and Shawn the lot
the longshot in the football tournament
odds wise was the Vikings I didn't get
15 to war well III don't have my entry
in front of me but I I mean I definitely
had the Saints pretty high cuz they were
coming out of the wild-card spot but
he's got that extra game Mike's got one
point and what I'll do is I'll see if I
can update the leaderboard after this
game take a shot take this out of the
shotgun engines they picked up two of
their fumbles yeah so they could have
had this amazing I mean you told me he
might be better than Bobby Wagner no I
mean this guy's I've never seen a game
like this look he just goes for the
jugular I mean we sees deke leading
dudes left and right first and 10 breeze
out of the pistol Hollett Oh drone
strike
[Applause]
take a shot there we go
alright who's 16 I've no idea who's 16
is the Hitman just collected body
asparagus is Maurice Harris yeah
someone's someone's touting in the
twitch chat I'm sure ace will take care
of them come on let's get to the line of
scrimmage come on we're under sergeant
you see Saints Breeze under center first
and ten yeah right hands off to Kamara
nothing there of course cuz they care
about the brutal at least I'm cashing my
Kamara under seventy seven and a half
hmm that's one lakh I'm getting right
Jesus Christ
Wow we need a gaucho on we really need
to get the the D gens only certification
process going there we go bleats it Oh
course he drowned see Perry the Hitman
this guy I've never seen I mean we've
seen he's better than Bobby Wagner I'm
saying yes we've seen kids or informants
have a couple games like this or he
really disrupts the game but now nothing
like this he had I mean he's at least he
separated what if you including complete
passes and fumbles one third and ten
presents to the end zone to the end zone
kakuka yeah all right that's one let's
go baby no alive and shout out to the
over batters that's a nice one now did
it see if the the damn can go down now
forty-eight points and the Vikings have
only had one turnover that pick six I
still think they got one left in the
chamber yeah they do
Kirk Cousins definitely has another one
in the chamber the Saints about to cut
the lead to 14 points for the Vikings
all right cram a weird game what are we
looking at over at my bookie dad AG
promo code TFT I'll give it to you as
soon as it's surfaces show the money
line is plus 500 the total is 58 now
they're down 14 plus 500 I mean maybe
this is a degenerate pet but here's the
way the game seems to work you're gonna
need like you're on a four-minute clock
to cut this to a single score I think
yeah and if you can do that you got a
shot now you can't let Minnesota score
here I think if Minnesota scores here
they ice the game yep totally agree any
points here from Minnesota the games
iced over on the ATC youtube see SN a 21
says five bucks they won't score here
and then immediately
r.i.p I feel you bro well you should
head over to my bookie dad AG seemed to
get involved get that money back dude
we're day trading over here huh I am
your investment guy but your investment
Sherpa the Kramer gang will tell you and
maybe some of the folks some of the DJ's
over the twitch head over to the
all things comedy YouTube page let these
people know what's up because the Kramer
gang is showing incredible returns this
past quarter incredible the PNL is
through the roof cousins under center
first and 10 from their own 20 5 here
1048 left to go coming back to throw
there we go
stop that clock this is the dish
I'm telling you overtime loading over
time loading that would be awesome
although it we would really need some
help to cover that six-and-a-half but
for the you know as a present partial
broadcaster it'd be great for the great
for the game itself and for Maya over
cousins out of the shotgun second and 10
from their own 20 5 get there let's get
some pressure boys they bring the heat
Oh incomplete
almost caught tip ball almost got it on
the ricochet and they seem more aware
and better at catching these tip balls
couldn't pull through their big third
and ten here for the Vikings and they've
only taken six seconds off the clock on
this drive so far perfect cousins out of
the shotgun on third and 10 turn over
loading let's go
turn over loading Zack K on YouTube ATC
saying is this on twitch yes you want to
go to twitch dot you go to twitch.tv
slash my bookie Madden twitch.tv slash
my bookie Madden or twitch.tv slash
sports gaming podcast it's not on mixer
I'm too old to know what makes ur is but
I should we be on mixer I thought about
it Shawn that's like that's like the
nerdy Xbox platform the Microsoft
version of twitch breeze under Center
after that turnover delayed handoff to
commodify the CEO lowers his shoulder
for a first down down to the six a quick
score here would be huge Colby let's go
you might not even need overtime shot
come on now Jared cook right now there
is hope I got to relax my swing here
breeze out of the shotgun first and goal
from the 6 o'clock continues to run low
pressure system coming through the
studio god damn it and there is hope in
Louisiana in Baton Rouge New Orleans
let's go imagine having a five to one
ticket everyone thought I was crazy I
doubled up on this - I took the +7 at
halftime
wow you're give me nuts that might be a
lock now I should have gone for the
middle I should have got I could have
had a 17 point a 17 and a half point
middle so we're on the attendings for
over on the YouTube ATC a K
Norseman says as a Vikings fan this
feels accurate yeah shout out both
lights up in the house bow vice focus
focus let's go
Saints are still plus 300 and they're
down seven at home and I mean we
predicted it I said they still had one
more turnover Kirk Cousins gave us that
gift turnover let's get a three a nap at
38 31 yeah I mean I caught it on the
exact play dundies back in this mother
phone my god and the over his back yeah
shout-out to the Oviatt better five and
we gave out the live over I think when
there was only like 14 nothing um I
think that live over I'm just to my
stomach right now it was 30 what I did
say over time loading multiple times but
I'm sick to my stomach right now I'm
gonna lose I have a chance to lose them
this guy can fumble - come on have a
chance to lose a plus 6a nap Zack K on
the ATC youtube this is way better than
Japanese baseball
hell yeah Zack you say and you're
supporting a local small business my
escorts gave my vodka I haven't tried to
watch that Japanese baseball but I
appreciate that movie mr. baseball
reason Japan Tom Selleck I think it's
career
but I think Japanese baseball got going
to play action my cousins back to throw
first and ten oh yeah how come the
Saints don't throw too tight in like
Kurt like cousins does and cousins
yardage prop is not coming in unless
they I think you just hit it there right
now it's too short
yeah because of the sax I need 68 yards
cousins i formation near midfield 850
level go back to throw interception
bullet pass it's I tell you it looks
like someone's on the sticks here and
we're gonna have to do a full
investigation could be Robert Mays off
in the locker and how's he doing
did we check him he's a minor on the
ringer right NFL podcast he's still in
the locker has anyone taken a podcast
from Locker though it is uh it's Co vid
19 friendly the his career got put in a
locker to her cousins under center first
and ten from the 26 miles yes get there
cam Jordan we call there we go Madison
goes down he's one second 11 but this is
dangerous because they get a field goal
I think this is route a bit screwed I
know this is good for the second half
the over 17 the the plus 11 if they get
the field goal it's good for that well
now there's a lot of people like brazen
Gator fans starting to have to sweat
these under high it live under big
numbers like 60s too much dancing
Madison not much there picks up a couple
third and eight from the 24 three points
would would make me feel better about
the cover I think then you're talking
about a Saints four-point victory but
the offense is turned on we've seen this
before unless Harry the Hitman can get
back involved and take someone's head
off cam Jordan needs a strip sack here
get their cousins back to throw
completes it to route up
she's so simple with the garlic
tight ends cover Kyle Rudolph I've
dollar free play next Saint score let's
go
interception cousins under center hands
it off to Madison to get fumble mother
Mary ouch there you know what could
really save us Colby we haven't seen it
in a while but we see it sometimes in
these games a blocked field goal that
could really that's true that's Barry
and Sean Payton does look like he has
braces something's weird there his face
looks for nothing nothing creepier than
a adult braces apologies that all the
listeners who have them cousins I
formation you know that's all right my
teeth are crowded I should be one to
talk people are saying that my mic is
screwed up I don't know what's going on
they're trying to get you dude are you
hit me are they messing with any
droppings I'm saying Kramer is muted
I'm not muted no that's that's his
personality bro vice thank you for being
an honest man cam Jordan she's
Alex Madison with the touchdown beats -
Mario Davis what the is have I may
have gotten excited and kicked my cable
could have happened all right well
here's the thing the Saints that's it
it's over now right now Saints to cover
six and a half that's cooked however
over time Saints plus 11 and Saints in
the second half over 17 that's alive and
well I mean they're down 14 here
Minnesota is gonna be playing prevent
coverage this is perfect time for that
second half backdoor let's go baby
mm-hmm Wow
I mean I'm sorry guys I who saw the
Saints losing in the opening the
wild-card round of the football
tournament we certainly did we were
telling everyone who would listen to
throw big numbers at them in the
confidence pool 62 total points Wow five
or six let down first should have been
eight turnovers I mean just filthy I
mean Brett clover checking in on the
ATTC youtube I had braces as a 20 year
old in college I think my wife did as
well for a year so who's the player of
the game it's gotta be Harrison Smith
you kidding me yeah I mean how many Kirk
Cousins has five passing touchdown
Rudolph is better than cousins he also
has to pick sixes right here one one
plus it mean Kirk Cousins is the only
reason New Orleans is in this game yeah
how many point I mean not to be cousins
hater but the Pick six and the
interception on his own 20 can they
update the return smart system here the
over definitely hit it I think I thought
we just called it the smart system I
don't know what the I'm talking
about all right
return the ball up the field use
your blocks come on Saints breeze out of
the shotgun here first and ten from his
own 25 back to throw steps up completes
it down but Kamara runs backwards
haven't seen that one just in and Harry
the hit man took a shot he missed big
you live to see another day alvin kamara
because that could have been a fumble
and that could've really ruined the
second half action that we got cooking
here potentially yeah so what are you
sitting seer your not cash in the second
half right now second in one completes
of the trig Nate Smith row first and is
it at first and I don't even know
yeah Colby there's a thing now oh my god
God forward progress yes right and it
didn't work
Zack K saying how often are we doing
these madness streams I dig it well you
can just go to sports game my podcast
calm you can click on Sims and you can
see our whole Sims schedule for the
month but our next we're doing specific
ones for the all things comedy and then
we got some going on our own twitch page
oh my god Smith man
why keep I can't hold on to it but they
nearly nearly intercepted and nearly
caught Harry and the Hendersons hit him
like I dropped the link in the chat John
yes but it gets uh we're not allowed to
send links to the atcu dojo fourth and
inches they're going for it they're
gonna hand it off to Kumar he's gonna
get stopped you
drew brees play action all right now we
have a shot oh my god don't look now but
now I have a chance for my I need twenty
nine passing yards of her cousins they
they're not smart enough to know they
should run every time he's gonna throw
the ball
I just like to catches I think I think I
need to I need I need to get lucky here
Shawn I didn't have my player prop at
least of Komara cousins i-formation
[Applause]
hands it off the mat assistant push back
by anal zone yeah you know second and
six
you always got to be ready for that push
back from anal soon
do you know pawns already all I do is so
f-bombs man what I think it was you that
said that last f-bomb Colby does all
right losing money here what am I
supposed to act like a Saint
yeah gee golly that's a disappointment
she doesn't understand her i-formation
play action go deep check sit down this
dude's assumed God he is the New Jersey
seven yards seven yards Shaun seven
yards more yeah
[Applause]
now you might you might get it Rudolph's
dad for one key you might get it yet
away you need like a third and eight I
I'm not always a shotgun cousins out of
the shotgun yes please are they gonna
call it play before the two boys Mike it
[Applause]
was the fumble we needed shine right
there
well Colby we'd also have three timeouts
you guys are still hopeful this is great
no if they kick a field goal 41 they get
a touchdown 31 we covered the second
half so it's a push right no 31 plus 11
would be 42 so we'd actually win cousins
out of the shack oh yes right second and
20 move to Madison right I need 7 Sean
let me get 7 a might throw here right
and throws some love in the HCC youtube
channel regardless of where you watch
and give us a thumbs up share it spread
the word oh come on guys I wonder if
they're piping the audio must not be
piping the idea of the headsets cuz they
had no idea what was going on here 37
they're down don't
on the ball perhaps in Kirk i-formation
no they do play where were these sacks
earlier no man just that's it just
brutal black field go let's go you know
what it is though cooks no longer a sim
God that move along Saints though we'll
have a chance to get a garbage touchdown
here for that second half backdoor
that's why what a score 38 points and I
don't get over 260 a rose 87 says SGP
I'll make Madden Sims greatly
entertaining every time fail you nearly
blocked well that's up and good thank
you for turn tuning in man and
appreciate the nice coming so close I
can't that's a bad beat right
oh that was so close to a bat I mean I
don't know is it is it a bad beat when
Drew Brees throws four interceptions and
two four zero fumbles Sean I'm talking
about my yard it's probably a few so
your totals whittled down to four years
shout-out to legendary Ajax Kramer uh
what's the latest number on the late
game which is a tipping off kicking off
Tipton are probably around seven o'clock
Pacific ten o'clock ease maybe a little
later we'll see how long it takes him to
grade the props four and a half still
Shawn the Eagles are four and a half
point home dogs plus 150 on the money
line 48 is the total do you want to give
me a what do you think about a money
line Pat Kramer two units to win three
units sure nice
yes how do we do this but you got it we
got to do a unit on the spread - all
right one unit on plus four and a half
yeah all right - on the money line Nick
2480 Colby is not picking the next game
pick Dundee - there's baby check that
out dad be be done Don Beebe great man
super fast guy who'll get
best wishes with his coaching at this d3
school breeze out of the shotgun I was
gonna be a pic truck come on Smith let's
go let's go I'm rooting for Colby to get
his second half yeah and hopefully
everyone else who followed us and then
the team total 17 and the plus 11 will
hit if they get this touchdown come on
let's go if I could just push for this
oh my god forbid they go for two no
huddle
all right that's smart breeze out of the
shotgun empty set has plenty of time
completes it near midfield Manuel
Sanders let's go he's gonna go for 400
yards bruised this just shows you the
trash trash of Drew Brees in this
offense dub j57 wants to know why does
Cousins look like Kai for bath great
question that's an upgraded arm talent
right there yeah breeze back to throw
complete now Emmanuel Sanders stopped
doing the first down motion Danny back
to the huddle I swear he went out of
bounds didn't get back to the huddle or
not the hole no seven seconds probably
have a timeout to back to throw it down
underneath timeout they use it all right
now you got two shots of the end zone
intelligent with the timeout usage
that's rare all right I'm what do you
think touchdown to Michael Thomas yeah
yeah sure
today right now it's a mass from the
internet checking in hash tag Sean
Payton loved Matt from the internet yeah
come on now get this thing going breeze
out of the shotgun just two shots to the
endzone don't throw it underneath they
throw it underneath they can't get
another playoff
steps up cheese checks his down
underneath get out of bounds at least
they don't that'll probably blow get up
on hurry up no huddle no they don't
son's celebrating the first and you see
so Jesus I hate you yeah it's my
favorite part of Zimmer is fired up in
the tournament Wow
Kramer we played three games in the
football tournament everyone has played
out the same way as the 2019 and it went
playoffs that's why uh stay tuned we got
a great late game coming up
oh boy how about that Shawn some unit
just came my direction brutal just
brutal man some units just came and now
that what's that for unit shown is that
the balance net is your balance Cramer
and we got two units on the eagles money
line one unit on eagles plus four and a
half then we're not going anywhere
Saint or not tonight so hacking out
we'll be talking player props oh wow
okay okay well Colby's gonna leave I
mean it shot it a shot and I will stuff
it's gotta go to a nose beer I
appreciate that sounds like we're gonna
be good nobody's gonna go take a good
hard look in the mirror
hopefully he washes his hands Cramer
let's take a look at some of these stats
I know we have some people hanging on
looking for these player props good game
CAS na 21 chicken in kelan Molson with
there being no sports on television
these days this was extremely
entertaining to watch thanks for making
my night guys
you rock you rock kelan subscribe to the
sports gambling podcast more importantly
stay tuned got a late game plenty more
action to go well I mean the story of
this game rushing props under Beauvais
saying he wants to be on the podcast
sometime okay though you're on almost
every episode what do we got here Shawn
sorry so we got Jubilee freeze oh hush
that oh of husbands yardage under
cousins touchdowns over I don't breeze
touchdown prop I don't know what it's
probably two two or two and a half so
definitely not winning that over maybe
losing again rushing props all under
yeah not nothing nothing sniffing
eight-and-under michael thomas just
absolute monster 11 catches 136 yards
crushing the prod the over props I would
have to imagine most guys went
/ with the receiving props unless your
name is Jared cook or Adam Thielen yeah
I mean I rode off went for a hundred
Sanders 74 TRACON Smith 91 Michael
somehow Dalvin cook had 9 435 Mike
Michael Thomas had himself a game and
that of course lose you too Colby dant
yeah that's a serious mush
I mean anal zone nice game 10 total
total tackles 2 for a while yeah I mean
if we're talking about defense you got
to talk about Harris where where is the
hit man did I pass him already or did he
somehow I have no tackles no the guy had
to have tackles he was destroyed people
left and right well there you go all
right he had ten tackles one
interception for reception yards I don't
even ride pass defense those are all
breakups and for forced fumbles poor how
do you have four floors fumbles ah
that's a play I mean who I don't I
didn't actually see who got the player
of the game but that's the player the
game no it has to be he had five
breakups for first forced fumbles and an
interception Sean he was he was
responsible for three takeaways plus two
fumbles they were covered back that's
crazy that's a wild that is some
wild wild throw this on the screen
real quick we're gonna throw this on the
screen real quick and we're gonna let
we're gonna what we're gonna wait for
management and they could have been more
it could have been like seven they
picked up two of their fumbles and we're
gonna wait for management to let us know
when we are good to clear out of this
game and they've gotten all the other
goodies all right we got 10 minutes
until Eagles hosting the Seattle
Seahawks Shaun's Philadelphia Eagles
let's go baby
four and
half-point home dogs as Sean will tell
you 2015 was the year of the dog and
hungry dogs run faster the Seahawks are
plus or a minus 250 225 on the money
line Eagles plus 150 48 and a half is
the total Kramer let's uh let's load up
some props talk about this next game see
what we're gonna do here prop wise give
some people some more winners straight
cash show me let's see well I certainly
you know we've seen a lot of low scoring
third quarters if you want to have fun
maybe you go under nine and a half for
that third quarter bet but if you want
to talk about the player prop Shawn who
do you want to hear Carson Wentz
let's talk Carson once your guy ginger
Jesus three oh five and a half is the
passing prop Shawn that seems awfully
high yeah I feel like Carson typically
isn't doing that that much the Pat the T
DS is 2-1 40 on the over and then your
place everyone smile Sanders seventy six
and a half rushing yards mm-hmm
interesting now just you every you're
looking at him now good yeah I got him
up Jeffery six-and-a-half catches that
it's weird cuz he gets involved a lot in
these Zach Ertz six and a half catches
63 and a half yards I don't know I mild
Sanders rushing yards man this is
interesting went touchdown passes
sitting right at to shout out to all
over yo couch I'm so happy cook got
injured that was well worth the 2k he's
in the Sky Lounge he's in the VIP room
hanging out with concept only for Wales
Wales only Sean any other props pop out
to you yeah I don't know I'm I'm trying
to wrap my head around what I would lean
the audience is surely patiently
awaiting what do you what Colby's gonna
take for his prop but while Colby thinks
about that and I already told you maybe
you wanna maybe you want to look to
under nine and a half
maybe you want to look under
nine-and-a-half here's what I'd say
Russell Wilson rushing yards 46 and a
half go over I like it Eagles have a
pass rush I think he's gonna be running
for his life a little bit here you know
I like to give you hot winters Sean I'm
gonna grab our media guides for the
second all right appreciate that uh I
keep going back and forth I'm looking at
the Zach Ertz six and a half catches I'm
looking at the mild Sanders rushing
yards I think about Sanders is gonna be
beast in real fantasy football
I had them pretty high in the top ten
fantasy football running backs podcast
which we just dropped however I don't
know I don't know about the Madden world
you know what what do we do here Cramer
all right I will my prep for this game I
like odd point total but also throw out
Zach Ertz receiving yards over sixty
three and a half gets it done just to be
clear you just went on did you just get
did you get silky on us do I have to
show the sliders again sure always just
make sure people know it's on the
up-and-up I'm gonna turn this music off
big ern on the YouTube ATC saying I feel
like Colby would love a over/under prop
on fumbles I'll tell you this pro tip
we're about to watch a man who will
resemble he will it will remind you of
the great Harry the Hitman and that's
Bobby Wagner he separates people from
the ball as well and I love that I'm on
the side of just absolute dudes who lay
would lay pipe you might have been say
long I share in their love of
playing by and we've seen this with
these mobile quarterbacks they can be a
handful in these bad and Sims we'll see
if anything's changed with the recent
updates but dangerous if he gets going
that's certainly it's really gonna be
tough to handle did you say you like the
over for that Carson Wentz are you that
that's 305 that's big
that feels high that feels high I don't
know where there
getting that from I mean honestly
Russell Wilson to 52 and a half that's
probably low you know or the Wilson did
you go on the right Wilson rushing yards
I'm going over because I think the
Eagles pass rush is gonna be a little
bit of a problem and he's gonna have to
run for his life yeah I wouldn't be
surprised I mean although I like Kobe's
getting frustrated over here what's not
working for me oh my goodness nice give
it a second and one I do like Chris
Carson under fifty nine and a half
rushing yards so those would be my two
official plays Carson under fifty nine
and a half rushing yards Zach Ertz over
63 and a half
going back no wonder the tight end well
huh all right Sean you get to choose it
what do you what kind of outfits do you
want for your Eagles I mean the throw
backs are so badass although we haven't
had good luck with them I think you
still run them back you could go all
black do they have a do they have an all
black with the throwback kelly green no
be kind of badass see did they wear all
black back then no I don't think they
wore all black back then no but that's
why it's a video game you can make
up
that is pretty yeah that you can't beat
that just go with that that's flawless
is there anything further back okay no
that's dog that's Kevin Cobb I
remember that game final answer yes you
gotta go with that it's a good move for
by you to sit it eliminates the
possibility of the highlighter uniforms
from Seattle can't possibly roll the
highlighters out oh good that's a good
thing what are we doing over here Colby
he's asking for the old school a Blue
Hawks Jersey I am on the Seahawks man I
think we gotta go with ice Iverson are
you sure you don't want the highlighter
I think we have to go with a white unit
yeah we'll figure it out hey JT
ninety-five saying yo push the game back
so my bookie has time to grade okay so
yeah well their bets graded tell my
bookie to push the start time by a
couple minutes then yes Big Dawg you're
in charge are you doing all right
say please first of all man Sean
Alexander
he was pretty good that's a gross
beautiful horrible it's not it's not
that's a classic but it's got it we
gotta go why did I have to have that in
white right keep going that's it that's
all they got now they gotta have the
old-school white classic home and then
can't you go down and just we can just
adjust the Jersey we can do this
there you go I guess I mean it's better
than there we go the gray slab let's do
that
Oh do all gray I mean there's an all
gray but this is an interesting all grey
they snuck some highlighter in there so
there's a little bit of a mismatch but
III think voting yes this is nice look
at Millennials this is nice all right
let's get out of here
our people waiting for stuff to be
graded is that what's going on they are
Kramer they are I understand you went
all in you need that money to get down
in the next game you want to use that
promo code TFT over my bookie daddy G
will we see weather for the first time
in the football tournament we haven't
seen weather yet and that'll be
interesting if we do that certainly I
mean if you've watched these Sims wind
really affects these games has a huge
impact so we get a windy day in
Philadelphia that could really impact
the game I don't know it's weird it
doesn't necessarily impact the total but
it definitely impacts people driving and
stuff like that Kramer yeah sorry I'm
just uh you know communicating to the
mothership trying to get people there
their money trying to push back the
start time so you can get your eg down
on one of these nice prop Shawn but DK
Metcalf he's a guy you like this season
in real life are you looking to take
five and a half or sixty five and a half
yeah I'm trying to remember Kramer do
you remember like did Wilson does he hit
Metcalf a lot in these Sims you know
what more than Lockett we see we've seen
him go to diss Lee we've seen him go to
the tight end but we've also seen the
way a lot of these teams philosophies
and game plans are changing so perhaps
this is a good time to strike and you
know what the
just talked himself into a little side
action over fought what do you think do
you go yardage or catches five and a
half catches I'm gonna go catches
because I think he gets a couple bubble
screens maybe over five and a half
catches for mr. DK well and warning
there if you also if you are playing the
catch prop and you're like Kramer
thinking those bubble screens a lot of
times they run these runs you're right
they catch the ball like 1 or 2 yards
behind where they're throwing them so
they grade them as rush and just
something just something to keep an eye
out but what are you guys on what is uh
what is everyone's favorite prop yeah
what do you what side are you on
what else did I take I said 9 in under
nine and a half 3rd quarter total I
can't give mine until I'm addressed it's
pick Dundee
all right pick Dundee give us your
official now you're on my side I agree
with that yeah I'm gonna take the
Seahawks and then I a prop that I like
is the under 65 and a half in tyler
lockett oh ok
so Tyler Lockett gonna have a huge game
Cramer gang let's grab Tyler Lockett
over four and a half over four and a
half catches and I don't really get
involved too much in the player props
I'm going over Zeki Ertz receiving yards
63 and a half under Chris Carson rushing
yards 59 and a half and of course Eagles
moneyline plus 150 Eagles plus 145 and
those are those are my plays Hawks fan
checking in on YouTube
ATC saying hashtag go Hawks see how it's
been pretty solid in these Sims there's
been some moments where they've had some
weird games especially in Seattle Kramer
do we know the overall team ratings
people are asking uh I we were just on
that screen I'd have to go back but I
can do that oh I gotta do everything
again I hate you why would it was a
trick Shawn we fell for it it's alright
we have some time at 7:10 now we're
given we're given the book a little time
to grade your bets so you can get down
in the next game and if you're wondering
why it take it's taking so long because
they're offering you player props on a
video yeah
exactly you're welcome things I'll just
say just say thank you they're giving
you action they're giving you something
to bet on eagles are an 81 ok not bad
for the Madden the Madden world this is
what we want Kraemer remove that
Washington thing that is highly
offensive I can't even you're right get
that off the screen
I'll please what are the Seahawks 82 yes
82 so pretty even matchup - four and a
half road favor that seems to be a bit
juicy right a little disrespectful what
did we decide we had the the retro yeah
keep going there's a gray one and we
went with the gray it was a beautiful
look it's not bad right there
you've there you go solid Jersey combo
leave this up for a little Betsy do
announcer we'll be giving out some free
place what do we what do we think would
be a fun free play Philadelphia Eagles
touchdowns well I mean all right so it's
up to you oh wow
Colby how dare you I mean I'll put I'll
personally put a $50 my book you free
play bounty on Carson wins oh my god
Kramer
it's happening alright you can put a
bounty on someone if you'd like ooh I
mean I really want Bobby Wagner to the
game but there's no way that dude gets
injured I'll say I'll say Kris Carson
cuz I'm taking his under rushing yards
Chris Carlson $50 bounty and Chris
parsley who's your guy one guy you get
to pick a bounty I already picked Carson
Wentz you can't pick him damn um let's
go with let's go Earth's all rights okay
so those guys are $50 bounties anyone
else gets hurt it's a $25 free play over
at my bookie dad you use that pro bono
TNT and Eagles touchdown
Jimmy hee ha no we're not we're not
doing eagles touchdowns come on that's
negative we got three Eagles no alright
then what do you want to do turnovers
turnovers are fun all right we got
injury yeah we do turn or we get is
hardly ever injured we'll just freestyle
well just freestyle it alright I'm
freestyling turnovers Jimmy he ha
saying he's taking my winnings on Game
one and making
the ezc Alex - 225 moneyline play have
to read the kid a story and have my wife
tell me how awful a father I am for
keeping the kid up until 10:00 all right
you could read him a story about how you
want some cash the story about how the
Minnesota Vikings went into New Orleans
they storm the gates of New Orleans
riding their ships Sean I have a
proposal for you
I feel fun prop at Odilon saying bounty
on the anti-semite Deshawn Jackson
that's a good one yeah yeah all right
Sean yes what was I gonna say God say
that we're gonna ride off into the
sunset with money in our hands god damn
it no it's god no yeah it's got oh my my
proposition for Sean we already have a
unit on the spread yes we're deaf two
units on the money line yep Carson Wentz
touchdown passes that's your side of it
okay Bobby Wagner forced fumbles oh I
like it all right I'll take that yeah I
mean Bobby was that a fan what do you
mean should we wait offer up some merch
I got I got enough going on too much
going on yeah we got yeah you know so
many so much action it's overwhelming I
feel like the Super Bowl it's FEMA the
Super Bowl remember that time I gave out
Patrick mahomes score first touchdown
plus 1500 on our Super Bowl preview you
remember that Shawn yeah straight fired
straight bar Oh skeletor's suggesting
field goal free place feels kind of
weird right well I mean field goals or
is it because it's like it's like oh
that's uh I like that Skeletor friend of
the program will do it $25 free play
each field goal we'll figure it out cuz
yeah field goals are boring and they
suck but at least at least you get the
$25 free play our people have people
gotten paid yet
I'm itching for this game now that I got
this fun prop with you both guys start
last
name starts with a W Sean that's
interesting
Wagner and Wentz that is the W is going
back to bathtubs
u-dub is a university in Seattle ah
that's a filthy act right there's only
one school and are you wearing in water
all be wearing the school shout out to
the City of Pullman beautiful shout out
to the city of Moscow as well Moscow
Idaho to be clear yes Russia can go
itself
Kramer Jesus this is the Internet
there's probably there's probably
Russian box city where I got that
delicious chickpea burger out of the
freezer one burger they're making
these delicious burgers they're usually
they're using an ice cream scooper
really good smash burger Lee a scoop of
meat on a pat on the griddle wait we're
definitely going there and then and then
I my dumb ass is like I'm not gonna eat
meat for this trip to a college town and
I get the whatever burger and they just
pull this like solid the salad break of
chickpea out of the freezer that moment
by me it didn't we get a nice rib eye to
Sean and oh yeah a bunch of delicious
meat when we went up to Washington State
we took a trip up there hung out with a
friend of the program coach Mike Leach
no you should check out uh we've had him
on the podcast coupons great dude
awesome awesome hang as you'd imagine
and Penn State yeah now we're now we're
Mississippi State fans as well and still
Washington State fans cuz they horse let
us hang out the press box and we bet on
the game and then we're cheering loudly
in the press box you're not allowed to
do guys forget where that's where we're
gonna kick the field goal yeah take a
47-yard field goal man I might be a
little windy buddy in full in Pullman I
can bang it in hey they might they might
give me a scholarship much like much
like Gardner Minshew he can put it in
when he's in Pullman him alright Oh a
couple three minutes left until we get
this game kicked off Magic Man Blanco
SGP glass of bottle black pearl black
barrel oh he wants to bet if Sean's
Eagles win and fold in paper boats for
Thursday doesn't get any better so yeah
I I'm bad
him he's a Packer fan which is hilarious
because he works for the septic
treatment company you could you could go
a lot of places there Shawn we are not
controlling either team are we sure we
want to we do actually playing the video
games would be weird we're not doing
that there'd be a lot more energy be
hard to get super super loaded well
wasn't it Jim Mora you were you were Jim
Moore jr. you were raving about your
second-place Madden finish well once
upon a time
what Colby's referring to is I once did
sit upon the throne of second place
across Xbox Live Matt in 2004 the one
with Vic on the cover and he flexed it
when we had Jim we're a junior I'm bang
he was my coach tomorrow just like okay
it was pretty awesome talking to Jim
Mora about doing smelling songs on the
sidelines
we call them decaf nose beers and you
can do the math on what it knows beer is
but yeah I mean he's just like smelling
salt smelling them and we will be doing
smelling salts for the Super Bowl on on
cam so stay tuned for that and yeah if
you guys want to know the schedule for
the all things comedy tournament okay
the football tournament just go to
sports gaming podcast.com slash a t see
family and podcast.com slash a TC kramer
are we good let's go let's get it going
are we ready yeah I'm ready for those
wondering why we do quick presentation
because that's the otherwise we'd be
doing a three-hour game to a nap Jones
Tower saying this is the field goal of
livestreams neck come on you can't in
mid-game we're grading everyone's action
a lot of people want a lot of money on
the early we get these people pay he
could be a fan of field goals no why
don't we think it's a bad thing you're
right this guy is probably Shawn field
goals win games including games for you
the double doink that was a field goal
I remember that game very well Jake
Elliott's 60 yard field goal 62 against
a giant was probably Justin Tucker who I
know as a friend of that cast I hate the
emoji
you let me know it's what I was
referring to your 47 yarder you guys are
you guys are just you you're just out
you're out there I'm gonna bang it in
Pullman it's gonna be great
now no one no here we go right here's
not doing anything with you let's go I'm
advancing to the game Sean good luck
then shout out to the brats stop that's
another thing we're gonna do for the
Super Bowl Sean we're grilling up some
brats at the brats op the best brought
pit stop in all of North America Kenosha
Wisconsin zone they mailed us a ton of
brats and cheese and we're gonna be
grilling those up for the Super Bowl of
the football tournament oh yeah you
haven't looked at the schedule what what
you'll notice is that the championship
games and the Super Bowl are all on
championship Saturday as we're calling
it yeah it's gonna be crazy streaming
back I mean first of all not every day
guy streams for six hours right nope or
is that normal out of them Eagles kick
it off Seattle will start the ball start
with the ball boom and we have some wind
look out snails have the wind at their
back to start the game these uniforms
are fire Russell Wilson under seven
positions and hand it off to Chris
Carson both huge I thought he was gonna
breakdance
that is not good for Mike Chris Carson
under rushing yards Jesus Christ are you
kidding me I thought for a second I
thought Cole we might have had a Chris
Carson prop now I realized it must just
be the game back because he's picked
Dundee again but his mush powers on the
who was your player prompt but I got
addressed as Dundee on that but was a
locket no hole yeah that's right I did
you 65 and 66 and Wilson back to throw
completes it to make a vector we go one
hold it up one down five to go baby
one catch this is like the Super Bowl
baby I'm I'm high fee right now is that
the is that I would they say I'm hyped
up I'm excited Wilson out of the shotgun
Seahawks on the move at the Eagles 41st
and 10 14 left to go in the first
back to throw little better he looks the
one god damn I am a prop god kramer
losing his mind
Wilson picks up 11 first down and then
to 29 Jalen Mills on the tackle danger
Russ getting loose this is a great
beginning of the game Kramer Wilson out
of the shotgun first and ten from the 29
he'll kick kick completes it underneath
is that is that him does that lock it
yes looks like Tyler Lockett he's
getting going only five yards I get the
reception prop though I maybe we can
both yeah I didn't take the reception
okay good I know I wanted to fade you in
a way that wasn't quite fading you what
was fading you I didn't want to be meted
thank you small small bets no Fred says
Sean's an idiot you have to clarify
about what Wilson i-formation hands it
on to Chris Carson County go back a
whole client Simmons with the towel no
it's not it's no that's it looked like
license Novus jerseys in the NFL game
listo Sam they are there gray are the
best I I think go birds in go parts and
if they can force a field goal look out
for this wind will sit out of the shack
on third and five only rush three spin
move completes it close to the first
down probably got it there we go there
we go kakaw that's Metcalfe with another
haul before you're a leader
I am the dungeon master are you kidding
me the props I gave you Metcalf over
five and a half catches we need only
four left he's got to Wilson under
center split I
hands it off to carson cuts it upfield
use your blocker man this Eagles defense
is looking soft olsson block nobody on
that plan out a great start for the
defense so far I like that you a 5 from
the 13 this is just the right amount of
highlighter yeah yeah it's it's just
highlight it's still not necessary
necessary well done Sean Wilson out of
the shotgun second of five from the 13
let's go Eagles come on big stop here
[Applause]
catch that right right in the hands and
our AP today Chris Carson under are you
kidding me Jesus come on
is that what you took Sean I took Chris
Carson under rushing yards that's not
looking good it's certainly though
Wilson out of the shotgun checks it down
on there Neil compete completes of Japan
e that's our guy rounded 5 our gal from
San Diego State former Aztec I went and
checked out a city a mistake basketball
game he was sitting uh sitting a row
below me nicely right there man talk to
her shot penny for a minute you know
love that great story yeah love that
he's a cool dude hey Wilson out of the
shotgun want us a lot of money person
goal from the five hands it off to penny
in there
so easy horrible start and Philly's
gonna get the ball in the second half
Sean oh god well congrats Seattle you
losers everyone's saying Kyle Kyle in
the chat all right so Seattle's up
7-nothing
Eagles at home Cramer what's the spread
well Sean as I head over to my bookie
dot AG I just got done using that promo
code TFT that's a great call and I'm
waiting for the lot the live numbers
show you always put me on the spot at
the right time you know that's all right
you can vamp I I mean I can't imagine
the number moves too much isn't this the
expectation Seattle comes out punches
them to the mouth and next thing we see
is a we're gonna see the bounty cash
Bobby Wagner will destroy herbs for a
fumble take it to the house rough start
for the Eagles but hey you know they're
at home they can figure it out they're
defending ups and downs not a great
start though for the defense so far I
don't remember that EA Sports logo at
Lincoln Financial no no it's graffiti
yeah break bring it down into the will
on this wind is serious and got hurt
with the return out to the 32 Cramer
tell me what that live line is can't
load I got Mahama haven't technically
all right it's fine first and 10 Eagles
take over when did their back I had a
hard time getting in there too man
it's crashing the system we got too many
guys on we're using all the internet
lens head of the shotgun first and ten
from their own 32 miles Sanders knew he
looked quick nice run up the middle
there or off tackle gives up six second
and four he looked very quick and Sean
he he's a guy he's a guy you loved
he's gonna have a huge year fantasy wise
knock on wood
well Sean actually knocked under center
second afford
he's just terrified some more
particleboard all right Wagner pitch out
Sanders has a hole oh yeah he's the
first down didn't need the Juke
hesitated there a little bit I think in
the first down first and 10 at the 43
and the Eagles on the move let's go baby
Eagles helmets are electric my bookie
Madden Daniel Gardner checking in fly
eagles fly let's go baby
live number over in my book you've got a
G six and a half for the Eagles there
the dogs plus 175 still the money line
Sanders off tackle the vample to same
look there the dog Kramer they are
hungry dogs run faster 50 oh my god
not since 2018 when they when Sean was
too late on the masked trend and ended
up not with the German Shepherd but with
a poodle hungry dogs run out let's see
Carson Wentz I put the bounty on his
head chunky you talk in that thing oh
[Applause]
wow poodle head just looks beautiful
just looks beauty waiting it out later I
wish everyone could have seen Sean watch
the Eagles win a Super Bowl it was like
watching uh what I would imagine a
walrus giving birth
sounds like when's 3rd and 7 completes
it to Zach Ertz let's go baby
danger zone in there going across the
middle with Bobby Wagner and that's what
is for Bobby Wagner
what is the Bobby Wagner nickname he
doesn't have a cool one like the Hitman
Bobby yeah
[Applause]
big balls Wagner I like it good job
Colby all right let's go
once under shotgun Oh Oh
hands it off the miles sander spins
balls laid some wood there no he's
walking with a limp he's walking like an
ozone popped up Bobby swag nerd who 40
justice suggests Wagner surname of like
a vacuum yeah company so maybe like you
know doing some cleanup not like big
balls coracle men's picks up to third
and seven from the 39 now people are
asking did we crash my bookie unclear
give it a second I'm sure they'll figure
it out is it dead sorry I mean third and
sapphire baby from the 39 wins out of
the shotgun hard count back to throw get
their heads time oh my god that's the
Carson was that no but you see behind
you for this hit the 56 yard I'm seeing
everything is green eagles are plus 4
and 1/2 is plus 175 on the money line 50
is the total head over to my bookie JJ
use that promo code TFT ng on YouTube
ADC why would anyone want to watch
someone play video games
we're not playing the video users 56
yard field goal from the left
[Applause]
wide right I was just about to give out
a $25 free play there's Hertz man they
should just put him in the game it's
funny too because you can use the
nickname Hertz for Zach Ertz after the
bounty cashes in you know oh I like that
again to be clear if you're new we're
not playing the game the computer is
playing itself and people are betting on
it over my bookie dad a cheap replica
TFT Wilson back to throw out of the
shotgun completes its to diss Lee I
think love that play call and we know he
likes going to dis lis he does he
catches would have been would have been
nice prop that there
second and five from the 49 the Eagles
need to give a stop here that was a bad
miss he had plenty of leg on Wilson
under center split I second and five
liras wind hands it off and he loses
yards course ledger Cox a man's hungry
let that man eat
loses - that's good for his under fifty
nine and a half on the school's third
and seven let's go baby
deal Birds he came Metcalf right here
third and seven oh he's got the defense
figure it out Wilson out of the shotgun
they're bringing the quarterback blitz
Oh
fleet wind is an issue I think both
quarterbacks having trouble here with
the wind I think the wind is real and
now that now seok's will be punting into
that wind this is gonna be interesting
Fletcher Cox sighting of course long
it's gonna be another five yard punt
could be is he serious it can be
dangerous they can get this to the 30
it's up out at the 11 that's actually a
great punt break over at their own 11
down 7 here early in the football
tournament
you're watching presented by the sports
gambling podcast my bookie Todd AG promo
code TFT and of course all things comedy
Jim cats on the YouTube ATC saying he
just got a face full of Wow ok
nice you're fitting in well Myles
Sanders nice little sweet play out there
picks up in six yards 5 carries for 21
so far for Sanders you took that over on
that no I didn't touch his props ok ok I
didn't know I think he's been updated
they've updated his numbers I feel like
I I think I'm doing better than he
normally like was like he looks so good
in that second half so this is expecting
I expect him to be really good
Allyson one side of the shotgun dangers
throw there to Deshawn realize Hitler
was bad Jackson can I just give a
shout-out to friend of the program Lenny
Dykstra this I just loaded up Twitter
and when I see Lenny Dykstra tweeting
DeSean Jackson - apologies in under 24
hours zero faked cancer Ron darling zero
apologies and one in the quarter years
Oh retweet that please once out of the
shotgun third and four back to throw as
time checks it down underneath the
Alshon Jeffery hangs over the ball gets
a first down Lenny Dykstra friend of the
program make sure to check out that epic
podcast the slime
[Music]
[Laughter]
love Lenny Dykstra he's a
character okay we're missing the game
now I was Sean with a catch we talked
about those crops hike nail that I
already did my play I was really
distracted by this tweet by Lenny
Dykstra that's a man went under center
first and ten from the 2825 left to go
all right here we go
boom Oh Oh make them fumble come on you
got that in you and right now our prop
is dead even
Sanders loses three second and 13
come on now let's go baby let's go
single backset double tight end or sorry
fruit items Flint's back to throw
thanks get off bystanders Oh deep ball
Oh No
intercepted yeah whoa oh my god oh no
Sean you up for that ball give up block
o the linemen chasing Kelsey with the
tackle takes him down to 48 that's like
a pun
[Applause]
this is Madden 20 with the updated
rosters now so this is not Madden 2021
oh nice ball there that Dorset Dorset
with the catch Darius slay on the tackle
second and for Zack K st. Sean is a
legit commentator Thank You Zack wow
it's like a backhanded compliment I
think that's what they call that Derrick
McKnight saying we're back so he's able
to get into my bookie Oh
use that promo code TFT shout-out to my
bookie Wilson out of the pistol here
second and four hands it off and they
lose yards again damn it
so this is great for my this is gonna be
a in rushing prop yeah horrible
start you loose it you're good you're
going the right way
third and six now from the 48 big stop
here for the Eagles need to get them off
the field Wilson out of the shotgun big
third down hard count
back to throw steps into it he loves
leads to disagree guess his 30s yeah we
go damn where where are my receivers I
need some I need some Metcalfe sightings
Luis Chavez Miranda on the YouTube ATC
saying love the show guys Thank You Luis
make sure you she's a thumbs up spread
the word peace and love you the man and
here's how you know Colby Dan that I was
watching some disc golf last night that
YouTube's trying to show Wilson back to
throw they bring pressure completes it
again to the titans' Greg Olson Greg
Olson and Gaddy they brought heat they
brought a safety blitz I feel like
there's been more safety blitzes as well
lately
I'm happy that it's actually linebacker
naked do yourself a favor
Google seventh floor crew and it's a
music video Greg Olson and some of the
other his teammates at Miami that's a
shot when they were in college
that's an all-timer yeah it didn't age
well let's put it that way
alright end of the first quarter only 7
nothing so under a better feeling
relaxed very relaxed like it only has
one catch five yards loving that Wilson
under center first and ten from the 26
split eye now they have the wind at
their back oh sure oh who is that to me
cleaning it I think it was McLeod on the
tackle
Carson picks up eight that takes a hit
and in Barrett saying y'all commentating
or playing poker I don't know what he's
talking about both well we are gambling
poker is a game of skill much like
betting on these Madden sims ii and ii
wilson of the shotgun empty sets and he
looks for long
he's got all these slides much like
poker when you're day trading aka
investing aka live wagering over at my
bookie dot AG promo code TFT you got a
no one to hold them and no one to fool
them amen kramer gang we heavily
invested early in this one we're looking
for an opportunity to pounce in the
marketplace
it hasn't presented itself yet it and
Shawn stacking the money Green and his
Philadelphia Eagles are staring down the
barrel of Russell the love muscle
Wilson's giantic as they leave 14 to
nothing
whoa Luis Chavez saying odds for second
half you can get all the if they have
live odds in game wagering so you don't
have to wait to the second half Shawn
Eagles are plus ten and a half morris
tanana mark saying can I say r.i.p
Carson rushing yards under yeah probably
but there's a long game it's a long game
and Derek McKnight saying first half
under twenty three and a half although
that doesn't look that good down with
the Seahawks just scoring he's gonna say
ho don't don't uh don't cash that ticket
yet all right Shawn the totals back to
forty eight and a half I'm waiting on a
money line I got to imagine you are
looking towards that money line I mean
at some point at some point I may look
to buy back a little bit maybe look for
a middle cuz I don't think the Eagles
are getting blown out here I don't think
the Philadelphia Eagles are getting
blown out at home I mean Vince bhopali
is gonna be rolling over in his grave
watching this effort this is disgusting
we got a rally here oh wait this just in
he's still alive apologies people are
calling for hurts to come in the game oh
no I go in for that guy the Redskins
sing we got away quick yeah that's true
that's and sorry bleep that from the
record I can't 2480 saying it
derek hough over on the ATC youtube
channel why is Russell Wilson so pale I
think it could be a side effect of that
concussion water he was hanging out with
Sammy Sosa recently go home
Wow down in Cuba huh getting the getting
the treatment one side of the shotgun
first and ten football be very good to
me
dude slates it's like no like
imagine being someone who's never seen
Sammy Sosa when he played baseball they
saw that documentary for the first time
and they're like holy Sammy Sosa is
a black guy like what I mean
monkeys could win the catch section
three he went down to Cuba right he got
some like weird yeah what a doctor was
like hey dude give me a couple million I
make you look great it was an accident
[Music]
Sanders loses to third and five here
from their own 30 Derrick thing tonight
when are we getting the database full
college football team preview podcasts
they're already dropping now you just
got to go to the college whose entrance
YouTube or a podcast feed look up the
college experience when its third and
five shotgun completes it to Zach Ertz
so there's wagging there nice pick up
there oh yeah we've previewed pretty
much we're already on em it's 31 yards
so over what was it like 63 and a half
that's looking decent right now yeah
Bobby Wagoner just throwing his whole
body at Zach Ertz when side of the
shotgun first and ten from his own 49
hands it off to Myles Sanders nice
little hole up the middle
Wagner is getting tackle screamer no
fumbles yet second and three but he's
laid a couple shoulder I mean he's no
he's no hairy the hit man I mean that
guy what do we say five forced fumbles
or five defendant passes for horses
fumbles and an interception that's an
insane status if God second and three
Eagles on the move at the Seahawks 45
Wentz with the hard count
[Applause]
Penza up the Sanders breaks into the
outside nothing there
Wagner was I mean Wagner isn't every
play he really is a sim guy that's
insane
it lost even gets a credit on the tackle
but they lost to honey they did third
and six let's go baby come on
Eagles Shawn this is tough it's got to
be tough to watch that I mean Carson
Wentz is just showing no fight what do
you mean they're driving down the field
Wentz out of the shotgun third six back
to throw has time Oh
the Goodwin defended it Sean you might
be in trouble because John list over on
twitch just said that Bobby had six
forced fumble than one half the other
day big balls might be coming for you
fourth and six the Eagles might go for
it here now balls but oh my god you got
to go for this this game is over so
punts is up down it come on
oh what a pun needed a break there they
can't win Aldo Vaughn it that was great
Carson 95 yard touchdown run
Daniel Gardner's say the boys aren't
fumbling that's a good sign let's go
come on Eagles get a turnover here three
and out need some momentum swing Harry
the Hitman hot is hitting safety in the
league will sit out of the shotgun first
and ten from his own six Metcalfe
emotion up top back to throw
quick go completes it to Metcalfe that's
shot that's three oh no don't be hurt
he's taking his helmet off no he's not
hurt know what he's doing he got popped
their picks up six second and four
let's get slay going come on is that
gonna rain shout out to boo 40 just as
you said he liked the the Illinois
preview team preview up on sports Kelly
podcast calm
the shotguns second of four pump-fake
has time gets pressured checks it down
wide open that usually doesn't work when
they throw this sideline but he was just
dead yeah no one was covering my locker
that's Dorsett now unfortunately in
story set you're right
somehow Colby Colby's on the right track
introduced as Dundee I'm a different
person there really is a correlation
first and ten from the sixteen Wilson
out of the shotgun nine minutes left to
go in the first half hard count pump
fake
big bring pressure Toby's guards
probably know it was like 15 I need
three more three more for the rest of
the game what a god damn it what a
goddamn sim god I am are you these
winners who was that on the tackle that
missed that yeah you got to make
them you got to wrap up look like jpp
there with a nickel Ruby Coleman you got
a key on the wrap up there bro right
along with the tackle by Carson 44 yards
not looking great though second and
eight eight minutes left to go come on
give the people a game let's go all
right I'm putting the dogmas back on
okay we got you ha transition nicely
Wilson in the shotgun second down and
eight
hands at the penny breaks the tackle
gets around yes
Wow first right that's antarious lei
showing up for his new team solid tackle
by the defensive back it's
who's 47 he needs to be cut he's Gary
he's missing tackles Russ is
unbelievable that's why they use a
liability bo Wilson
i formation first and ten from the 46
pins enough to parson go wash charge
there he goes a couple a dragon forward
well you the total use second and ten I
think it's like 59 something 59 and a
half he's got 44 second and ten seven
minutes left to go they need they need
some points before half are they in
field goal range right now Kramer the
wing is behind them now no I think I
think the winds doing weird chick is out
of the pistol play action oh my god what
are you doing oh my god huge play by
Darius slide let's go dude that's ball
game saver
dude he's beaten him so bad so what the
ball Fletcher Cox doing he's
standing right there and like Jukes out
to my side I thought I mean come on
Oh ruff sees it third and 10 to bring in
heat
Jesus wide open Pringles my easy money
shoutout to Abel cash and tickets Oh
welcome to the family boom I'm not even
sweating over here favored just easy
cash
I feel pretty relaxed I have a lot on a
lot of action I do I mean my Wagner
forced fumble verse went touchdown props
looking great
Wilson hard count out of the I formation
incomplete and we're almost a halftime
Sean I noticed that 5:45 says to go ask
game this flying by I mean we started
late we've only been going for 27
minutes this is unbelievable Wilson out
of the shotgun second and 10 from the 29
know that caps motion and up top spin
will bite Wilson
checks it down underneath the dish
should put his shoulder into him Sean
13 and a half plus 13 and a half for the
Eagles right now plus 425 on the money
line 46 is the total are you are you
shoving all the chips right now I'll
stick with what I got wait wait for
another touchdown then maybe bye-bye
low-grade concen
this feels like an Eagles game and I'm
an Eagles fan Wilson under Center
i-formation first and 10 Carson oh man
not much there stay inside he had some
room there picks up one second to 9 what
Cramer one of the Giants playing oh
that's right they aren't they didn't
make the playoffs got them the Eagles
lose in the playoffs and they beat the
Giants they've swept them they got say
to your draft pick waste of his body
Derek Barnett is in the car for their
five what's the number Shawn 59 and a
half he's down to 49 but you're looking
better third and 15 from the 23 well how
high did he get he got over like 48 or
49 right yep Wow and if you're not Y if
you're in the twitch channel the my
bookie Matt and twitch channel head over
to the all things comedy YouTube page
videos like us can you pick up 17 know
what hit is over though 51 and again we
were circling props in the second
quarter are you serious what investment
service is giving you that kind of
return Shawn are you 27 29 minutes
you're welcome hmm
he'll go here for the Seahawks keep
questioning the chat this Vegas Dave
caffee's games 34 yard field goal is up
and it's good
Seahawks out to his 17 nothing I'd like
to challenge him to put out a whale play
on the football tournament Super Bowl I
think we can get bit get his attention
Kobe sure I'll deploy deploy picked on
deke dundies on the case in the land and
I want a well play for the football
tournament Super Bowl all right we have
a field goal which means a $25 free play
up for grabs
what do we what are we doing Cramer I
mean if you're gonna put me in charge I
always you know I want to see people set
up I want to see where you're walking
tweet us you watching the game what
you're doing what you're getting
involved in to be clear like you're set
up not you yeah he doesn't have to be a
picture we did a contest where you had
to send in a picture of a review and we
got a couple people taking selfies of
themselves which is funny and hilarious
at the same time all right John yes it's
uh Eagles not off to a great start down
17 here in the first half but hey it's
early Emmett if you're a Philly fan plus
450 it's just got it's so juicy so juicy
now Bobby Wagner has had a full beard
you know it's coming Wentz back to throw
they present into the middle spin move
spin moves spin move and he looks to uh
here's the
Waggener do wear plenty of room to run
takes a shot come on
what is it the Seahawks doing up there
like a choreographed yoga routine oh
[Applause]
that's funny
did they do one of those things where
they dant they jump all the same way
Shan you buying that money huh yeah why
not
look I just put it all on once under
center first and ten from the 46 Goodwin
in motion he gets the handoff nothing in
there second a nine all right let's
check it a tweet so far over at gambling
podcast for the $25 free play keeps
sending them in send us in your setup
how you watching the game what you're
getting into and Sean the live number
over at my bookie dot AG is still Eagles
plus 13 and a half it's Meg we remember
to use that promo code TFT money line is
plus 450 45 is the total social thing
get some points here before half which
they desperately need to do second and
nine wants out of the shotgun
shout out to MP fewer no targeting your
right and Colby's camp looking for weird
calls oh there we go
down he goes Collier with the sack clock
continues to run third and 14 fucking-a
I hate this game
Shawn this sucks I'm sorry I thought
it'd be good for the brand if the Eagles
advanced we could have the dogmas for
another day really the best thing is a
comeback victory whence play action
third 1400 come on hang on do it
Deshawn hey you know he catches like he
has hot takes on the Internet
not well Wow he wanted nothing to do
with that ball come on that was a great
ball to putting into the wind 130 left
to go time for us go great fun
all right we got a winner
no what are we winning $25 free play
Congrats to Alex Cunningham also happens
to be an Eagles fan so that's I'm sure a
coincidence Eagles plus 14 plus 115 on
them on the line there plus 500 on the
money line now China will sit out of the
shotgun complete bolo who is that locket
what's he at right now I think he's got
two catches how many young not a ton I
think his first catch was like three
yards now it's five five what's the
number forty-six so I know it's like 60
60 20 20 all right fine what Dad to burn
a timeout there
one minute left to go in the first half
Seattle two time-outs Oh Pete Carroll's
nose is hilarious in this game it's
crooked like they went out of their
way to make sure his nose damn I
appreciate that I mean that's great
Wilson back to throw completes it to
Olson gets out of bounds oh he picks up
a cup hold on what's this defense
they're playing I don't know not a good
one and their defense usually pretty
solid at home like if they were on the
road I would understand but their
defense at home is pretty stout usually
second and six I mean Russell Wilson
just picking them apart right now Wilson
out of the shotgun second and six will
pump fake their spin move looks to run
down just having himself a game right
now
what was that 246 a night that was easy
money although they use their second
timeout can I can I can I be defeated
this is scary though they good I hear in
the news is scary what do you mean I'll
give a Shum hittin props this game
I want y'all to win so the Eagles move
on it's better for the brand empty set
trips up top Wilson out of the shotgun
first and 10 completes it underneath son
of a stop throwing it I got over
four and a half perceptions there Cramer
gang we're gonna win all the bets we're
gonna literally win all the bets that's
the first down at our line 32 yards on
par they have one timeout left
hopefully they burn eight nine and mess
up the was like 66 and a half
letting a lot letting the clock run here
from the 32
listen back to throw spin move completes
it underneath timeout then they just
kick the field over there
yeah time that's smart let's J seem to
be smarter letting it run all the way
down and they'll probably just kick the
field goal yeah that's fine not a good
start to this first half strangely I'll
say this feels like the Eagles should be
doing worse you know I guess it's only
20 only 20 feet you know what it is he's
not wearing a visor show no his lucky
visors not there his coat is not exposed
39-yard field well with the wind at
their backs we think it's up and it's
good yeah yeah up to a 22 nothin lady
Jesus Christ look at the sweat look at a
drip coming off Myers right now feeling
good first half under wow that was a
sweat yeah 23 and a half that cash is
Shawn the Eagles money line is up to 6
to 1 that means if you bet a dollar you
can win 6 on the Eagles oh yeah we have
seen comebacks in these city absolutely
have especially at home 44 and a half is
the total 17 is the live number 17s
insane I mean the Eagles aren't gonna
get shut out
Alex Cunningham checking in does the
computer account for the Eagles being
the second half team
I hope so Alex I hope so we're counting
on that there are typically ebbs and
flows I will say I'm a little worried
about my third quarter under 9 and a
half right now because it does feel like
there's gonna be a scoring outburst soon
will the Eagles even try to score here
no
Wow he can't destroy them no they're
probably nail like well
they maybe they'll go for they have time
outs now on a quick pass there go down
there you're gonna do a run quick pass
and then a Hail Mary Carson Wentz is not
a little I mean I I would let him
check it out well maybe you'd bring in
that maybe you bring in hurt so he can
reach the end zone
oh he doesn't even have a good arm went
under center pins off the mild Sanders
now they call timeout do two seconds
left you're gonna get a Hail Mary
they will having 61 yarders funny
they've had a they had a near Hail Mary
did they haven't won they had a deep
ball touchdown in one of these simpler I
think it was like a Hail Mary but all
right I think you're right yeah they
have first and 10 from the 39 last play
of the first half
Eagles down 20 than nothing let's Wagner
Blitzen yeah I was gonna say just go
after him plenty of time airs it out up
top and that's into the wind
incomplete wow he really couldn't reach
the air they should have brought in sub
film maybe Hertz I don't know someone
does the kicker have an arm Kramer the
Giants suck all right I mean I
appreciate you chip chirping at me
talking about the Giants we're talking
about them now there are dog
franchise I mean 26 the last 30 games we
mark my words go back into your locker
over there the washington professional
football team or the New York Giants
will be the NFC East champions this year
Wow I like this mark never heard it here
Freddie will not mark my words Sean the
Eagles not doing anything particularly
well well and again I did I hopefully I
deterred people from taking Wentz over
300 five passing yards that was a that's
not looking good we really discussed
that somehow didn't make it into my
portfolio for this game Russ he's having
a nice game through the air to shown
only four incompletions yeah no
touchdowns though from either
quarterback Wentz somehow for only forty
nine yards receivers kind of letting him
down they've had some drops just offense
hasn't gotten
I'm going at all Sanders doing okay
running the ball nothing amazing
you got any 76 and a half I think was
the number he's kind of in the middle
he's on there he's on the way I mean
this was this was the lock city I threw
it out there yeah where props are money
ask the Kramer gang in the chat on fire
right now and Carson I had under fifty
nine and a half your little horrible but
somewhat alive we'll see I mean they're
up big so maybe these are panels do some
accounting here so I have Metcalf over
five and a half he's got three
I got lock it over four and a half
thanks to Colby sorry I have three so
I'm both of those look ok what else do I
have here I don't think I have anything
else Sean did you have anything you
wanted to pay attention to here well
yeah the Kris Carson records I had over
sixty three and a half so I mean you
know on his way to mushing Lockett what
was the number I think 66 or 67 so right
there these these numbers are pretty
tight over my bookie dot AG but you got
to think the Seahawks if they're up at
the 4th not gonna pass as much use that
promo code TFT indeed Bobby Wagner done
a lot of stuff no forced fumbles me and
Sean are pushing right now he's kind of
let me down a little bit yeah come on
look at this he's having a decent day
he's got eight tackles three tackles for
loss yeah that's a pretty good pretty
good first samples get the ball he goes
get the ball to start the second half
let's go will they have the I think they
will have the wind at their back for the
fourth quarter right cuz it goes one in
four and then two and three battles
kicking right to left that's the
direction yeah so the Eagles are going
into the wind third quarter yeah and
then they'll have the wind at their back
yep for the fourth quarter that should
be huge but need to get that offense
going just get some easy passes going to
Zach Ertz look at this guy look at this
guy Mohawk that's a badass
punter you don't want to with that
guy having himself a game right now
arguably best game
best player in the Eagles right now is
the punter never never a great son
Dallas got her looking like he just got
back from Disneyland come on got her get
Goddard involved he's had a quiet night
well he's doing kicks still nursing that
knockout
yeah he did right sucker-punched what
did they what did the second half action
looking at the second half action Sean
let me refresh the man the Eagles are
just down and out second half Eagles
minus three so that's an adjusted 17
what it was right before the half for
the Eagles to win the second half on the
money line so just like adjusted plus 20
is minus 145 that feels like a decent
bet total is 24 and a half the team
totals Sean Seahawks 11 Eagles 14 man
Eagles the score first - 1:30 that might
be well they're devoted Wayne that's it
I would stay away from the e Hawks is
the side that just pound Eagles plus 17
Sean you want the money line for the
game what's the money 107 to 1 on the
Eagles right now it's very tempting I'm
not I can't advise even though I am a
hashtag that'd be a hell of a way for me
to hedge I mean if you take away the
return yards a that you guys only have a
hundred and three total yards yeah it's
pretty bad they they're often snack in
Seattle's defense has not been a
juggernaut and these Sims mm-hmm they're
playing good people want to know if
college Sims are coming back well maybe
we'll see you never know sim guards are
always up to something
yeah the sim gods also have to take some
time to go on vacation to go to the the
beaches and you know explore Vision
Quest and wear your mask yeah I'm gonna
wear a mask and then I'm gonna get to a
beach in camp and not be your
near people and fish and swim dude and
jump off a cliff and look at stars and
just you know get back connected with
the universe do my dog caught a fish
last night that's dope in Venice yeah
and the a the ocean really yeah it was
I mean it jumped up to the shore but it
was like flopping around and jumped back
in he jumped after it and he brings it
back in his mouth man nice shine nice
job mud doing a big-time
John s saying nerds well you too Bates
hopefully you're not talking about us
because we're not playing the games that
would be nerdy to play the games real
jocks like us watch the games and bet on
them that's whiskey and that's what
alphas do I dare you to stay in bed on
the game you nerd yeah Janice is
too scared to bet on the game you know
you know what a nerd would do they
wouldn't bet on this no sir nerd
yeah
Skeletor what time are we restarting now
if it was John Tesh it'd be different
right why am I getting a what a WTF from
Nick over in twitch I don't know Kramer
he's probably uh he's probably unhappy
he didn't ride with the Kramer gang here
on the night cap how rigged this game is
and wants to know who's on the stakes
and why why the Eagles are getting
dominated here at home highly
unrealistic let's get it goin Kramer
let's kick the second half off baby
are we ready let's do it let's do it
Bobby Wagner forced fumble first drive
skeletor so 757 all right being selfish
Skeletor are you being I feel like
everyone's got their pet spayed out come
on are you being selfish right now
Skeletor that's not cool bro I can't
believe Lenny Dykstra tweeted out a
Shawn Jackson to apologies in 24 hours
zero face cancer Ron darling zero
apologies in one and a quarter years he
really hates round Lenny Dykstra and Ron
darling have a serious beef he was
really itching to be mad about that
hilarious and of course if you want to
see when we're gonna be on again just go
to sports gaming podcast.com click the
sims button up there that'll give us
your the whole schedule we're gonna be
on tomorrow night and Thursday night
doing more Madden Sims and then we
return with the football tournament
next Tuesday July 14th of course all
games kicking off 8 East Lake games 10
East and give us a follow on Twitter at
gambling podcast and of course subscribe
to the sports gambling podcast an apple
podcast where ever great podcasts are
found now it's time to go Kramer oh yeah
let's do this
enough shot have we discussed
the Antonio Brown Seahawks I don't know
I mean you you can't want if you're
Seahawks fan you don't want that right
now you guys don't need receivers you
got DK Metcalfe Tyler Lockett you can't
risk rolling the dice with Antonio Brown
that guy's a firecracker first and ten
from the 25 once out of the shotgun
all right Wagner Sanders motions out
back to throw checks it down underneath
the Earth's can't pick up much cuz
that's whether it's does second and
seven it picks up three no yak he is not
yaker it's not a yak man second and
seven from their own 28 I don't
understand like he's I mean cuz I don't
yeah I believe DeSean Jackson's not an
anti-semite but how could he how is he
so dumb
he's a football player he thought he was
showing off by taking a photograph book
he's like look I'm an intellectual look
I'm reading a book man you see this book
he's reading it's so true and he thought
he was like he went to sleep thinking he
was smart yeah oh man DeSean you're on
that next-level stuff you read eBooks
like did now that went to
Cal Berkeley yeah Wow who took his SATs
third and one Wentz under shotgun
I mean Kyrie Irving went to do can he
thinks the Earth's flat goodsmile
Sanders breaks the tackle first down low
low low they just got a third one yes
they did
that doesn't happen on that was funny
yeah the Flat Earth with Kyrie I
mean he he's now he's right he's walked
it back saying he was joking but
right just like just like the Sean
Jackson's just if you ask that guy who
Hitler was or Wedmore Lord to happen he
would have no idea
he might know he would know when it's
under center I don't think he this huge
old four-mile sander he looks good Sean
get in there
picks up seven second and three often
spine a lot rhythm here early in the
third
let's get some points guys come on
dougie P Bobby Wagner forced fumble come
down hey you know we haven't even really
seen a big hit from him Wentz out of the
shotgun second and three back to throw
complete first down
his colony states tumblin check confirm
that was bobby wagon Wow why was that so
loud in my ear
a this stupid game who's on
the sticks hey this is gonna be the prop
I'm now leading 1-0 on Sean Bobby Wagner
one forced fumble Carson Wentz zero
touchdowns gotta get three years let's
get seven Bobby big balls Wagner Wilson
out of the shotgun second and nine the
red X means he's gonna throw an
interception right yep go to back to
throw broken up dangerous throw there
and Seattle has the wind at their back
here goober same vote in the
YouTube Asian odds of vote and powerful
message low voted I'm a voter look
Hilson added the Shaka and third and
nine play-action has time looks to run
slides short of the first answer is it's
a 61 yarder with the wind at the back 77
yards he's got 61
no I'm saying yeah does he know they're
gonna they're gonna try I think you
would put it here no this is the kind of
thing they try you're right 61 yarder by
him god mom is got the legs he's got the
leg from the left hashes
we missed the net damn the net holy
that's a bad move so Eagles catch a
break here Smith sighting and this is
this is that I think the time you want
to head over to my bookie might be some
value use that promo code TFT eagles
plus 17 plus 800 on the money line 43 is
the total I have under nine and a half
of the third quarter Kobe I didn't like
that at all when Thunder Center hands it
off to Miles Sanders but the wind is
strong so the Eagles will have to get to
the 120 yard line and burn field goal
range maybe 30 30 second and 525
I think Metcalfe is still at three
catches it in my my score book when it's
out of the shotgun second and five from
the 44
[Applause]
handoff to mile Sanders Branson to the
outside nice run there shot the best
offense it looks a lot like they're
taking the ball out of Carson Wentz's
hands yes got to mouth Sanders kisses
the hot in this type of offense might be
better suited for a guy like Jalen Hertz
I would agree I see what you're doing
there and didn't go yourself bubble
screen - oh that's a horrible idea the
bubble screen more of that please loses
three I had to make sure I had some
prepared material when it came to you
know his shoes that's pretty fire bobby
Wagner's got gold shoes all across the
board twinkle toes that's that's the new
nickname very Ric Flair like twinkle
toes went out of the shotgun second and
13 that's a kimono they're saying
incomplete remember when that dude
dropped the ball before he got in the
end zone that was the most the Shawn
Jackson thing to do - not even the
dumbest thing is that we could fumble
he's the ultimate he could fumbled once
out of the shotgun third and 13
third and 1200 and another drop is the
under third quarter nine and a half is
looking delicious gag the Kramer gang is
just floating on a beautiful boat
through the river river man
can't wait to see those videos 49 yard
field goal into the way no way
blessed might be a block man oh whoa I
mean come on this is such look
no it's real to me man 49 yard field
goal is never short in anime keep
showing hurts I think that I think
they're trying to imply trying to say
something why would the game keep
showing the backup quarterback
interesting is it time is it time to go
to the bullpen Wilson out of the shotgun
first and ten from his own 39 righty
it's gonna turn over guys come on play
action completes it out of the backfield
yeah four or five it's getting close to
gonna notate this for four forty twenty
senior to pick up second and two the
player props make this so much
better player props are dope shout-out
to my bookie for making that happen
Wilson out of the shotgun second and two
[Applause]
play action no there's County goes
dockside it's a big cops noses
one-third three let's get this first
down Kramer I like yeah I like the under
in this quarter so like maybe a punt and
then we're good
just want to get it to pass three scores
you know I mean I'm good
Wilson out of the shotgun third and
three from the 46 you're prior right but
I'm hard count Olson emotion
kids enough to penny there we go whoa I
don't know if he got it nine inches huge
stop by the eagle-headed do we get a
review no review look we got a review
punt it punt it pumped it out of the end
zone go for it
don't be a now there come on
they're they got a pun the red
line is not official fourth and inches
Seattle had to punt deep punt out of
bounds at the 24 Wow
horrible punt even with the win there
Eagles take over on their own 24 down 20
still you're under a third quarter nine
and a half's looking good Cramer I'm
just I'm I need one more Wagner fumble
yeah I gotta feel good about this extra
unit I'm winning once out of the shotgun
1st and 10 from the 24 bubble screen
hate to see that it's not gonna work
DeSean Jackson nothing there he's really
they're doing a goddamn thing moves the
clock why do they keep running the
bubble screen Sean I just did the math
if the game ended right now we would be
all square Lou Wentz under center second
13 I mean is your dad watch gambling
gods are listening Cramer is doing
everything he can to change himself God
Oh default in the middle Oh complete
Susie near midfield who the hell is that
Jim Mike quick back on the team I mean
Josh Perkins sighting oh wow Wow nice
ball by Wentz could wrap by perco he was
wide open it seems it hit okay maybe
they forgot about him
whatever it takes first and ten at the
50 it could be the spark they needed you
keep talking Cramer first and ten
check sit down nice the Sean Jackson go
30 25 20 this is getting interesting
it's getting interesting
come on boys down at the 19 let's go put
it in and they're doing this into the
wind the wind can be really devastating
we saw the Browns beat the Steelers in
Madden May Hamels just because of the
wind yeah really
to score a touchdown in the end they're
barely in field goal range right now
play-action now they're not in probably
not in field goal range doing Jerry
Jack's right in carson wentz his face
disrespectful
Down Goes once he's got it is he walking
with a limp is he perhaps he's injured
maybe we needed to take a look at the
backup that's a horse collar it's a
horse collar 12 personnel so it's under
center
so some Sanders alone back why do you
keep running the bubble they do
this you're cursing this sim these sims
it really does look like this Sean
Jackson they don't get it here it's a
43-yarder yeah I don't know that he's
got no way they're gonna use the field
range what was the last one 48 he's 9
range went out of the shotgun third and
16 100% he's not around
back throw can't take a sec like oh my
goodness this
Oh No Sean's getting angry that's just
this game Wow gotta throw the
Eagles are yet to score a point Sean
I've noticed that right great inside
this is a yard closer than the last it's
not gonna make it Kolby we know you guys
aren't like some spend Galilee's with
your yeah I'm ready that that fools got
you a goose egg at this point I don't
even want him to get hurt I don't even
want him to get hurt alright Cramer gang
you're welcome under nine and a half 3rd
quarter that might as well be a cache to
get so good Wilson under center Chris
Carson walks up a couple I'm so good got
seven
I'm the creators creator EAS programming
his trash I good media guy that's what
side you're on I guess what's that
what's everyone got throw your bets in
the chat Wilson under center second and
seven from the 40 hands it off Carson
picks up a couple there when I got
tackled from behind fell for third and
39 yard shot or 10 do you have is it 59
and a half 59 and a half so you have ten
yards still yep might get that I don't
know we'll see it's a weird game this
win the wind really this game up
Wilson under center third and three
penny randomly gets a bunch of running
this
and down he goes all right doesn't pick
up much their fourth and one another
three and out by the Eagles and that's
it we're gonna we're circling it Shawn
under third quarter nine and a half okay
if you bet that I would get upset
watching this you know that's also flat
up fourth to one my wife Solaris she's
like you can't get mad cuz that fake
egos wanna muck well we had money on
guys on senator Clovis enter some clips
give her the best of another bad punt
ones will take over at their own 26
first and ten let's go drive down and
then flip the field let's go come on
drive down kick a field goal right
before the end of this quarter now
touchdowns only one side of the shotgun
first and ten
nice pastor goes up and grabs it he's an
okay guy who's actually catching the
ball for for a 60 no he needs three and
a half more yards you got that it's a
good ball that's a lot it's feeling good
they're gonna be passing the rest of the
games they're losing
I noticed that first and ten from the 48
empty set lets out of the shotgun
back to throw complete over 63 and a
half let's go baby
there you go no chance he gets a fake
seven bubble screens done that's it
hurts that's why he's good to bet on
these player props you don't have to
worry about him going backwards
Christ
Wentz out of the shotgun 1st and 10 from
the 33 run the ball here here you go
[Applause]
wind oh that's a highlight are you
kidding me Sean
okay J right people thought I was crazy
making the number to fantasy football
running back let's go baby Eagles on the
move make this extra point Jesus
something it's good and you want to talk
about hard work Sean Kolby damn pick
Dundee the database is along the rat eg
victory
fly EGS Eagles
I'm not they're gonna do the whole song
you mean to interrupt the promo
Nicole be damned panic patty C are
breaking down all 130 Division one
college football teams episode by
episode going alphabetical starting with
the power five just dropped what Georgia
Tech yesterday today I think Indiana may
be is dropping as it did already
retweeted they already saw that yeah so
any anywhere you get your podcast search
for the college experience a whole
episode dedicated to your team every two
years like literally your team because
every unless sam and colby even was like
you know i kind of want to do a couple
of the FCS teams to i think i might have
to surprise some people there you gonna
drop in a little north dakota's shake
off into the wind by some strong yeah
Shawn will listen definitely dude they
got a quarterback tre Lance 28
touchdowns last year zero interceptions
Mel Kiper some of the other guys got him
projected as a top ten pick word is the
the database have them well it depends
on this season I want to see I'm really
excited to see him play organ organs got
one of the better secondaries I'm
excited for the return of the the bubble
screen and I'm excited for the data base
the return of the Dan to base college
football rankings yes what's the only
rankings I look up there you go man we
do our top 25 no spin zone no preseason
yeah that's the key no preseason ranking
so no bias will scream oh that's
beautiful
- penny oh good job I garyun the Eagles
are coming back put your 4 is up put
your dishes up Sean
give me the cash register because I just
cashed that under nine and a half for
the third quarter Cramer you're on fire
I'm looking on fire 13 point game it's a
big play right here big play to start
the four I need a met cat I need some
Metcalfe catches he's going going into
the wind third and six Wilson back to
throw has time holding X coming back
hope I'm glad that's a holding cuz that
was any well what oh sorry rough wood
was it a catch I think it was yeah
was it a catch wait wait holy we're
big Kanye Necessary Roughness Jesus
Christ
big catch I think it was a catch because
look they have all the 28 now that's a
cat how many yards was that Wilson I
formation first and 10
it wasn't off the carson not much there
how many yards was that it had to
because it was lock it i know i ii in
seven Necessary Roughness i think it is
just catch but i don't know did he catch
it yes he bought it and they gave him 15
yards he caught it 243 what do you know
about how long you think that was was
that a late hit or a router roughing the
passer
it was on the cornerback wow that's
that's a cuts a call
Wilson out of the shotgun empty set
second and seven and that's that
win coming into play he completes a I
think I lose my bed I might have already
lost I don't know how long ago that
wasn't more than 27 100k third seven big
third down it for the Eagles he was open
Wow
let's go D come on get a stop and the
wind is gonna determine this game show
Zach would be huge here Wilson out of
the pistol just run it's play-action
[Applause]
stop short Wow
ran into a cement wall goddamnit
Sean the the I mean when this number re
pops after the Seahawks score is that
when you're gonna grab the Eagles money
line you're really just gonna chase
you're gonna go deep deep dark place
it's gonna stop here go on Stan let's go
boys Wilson
checks it down - Carson oh dude yeah
good tackle by Gary he had some open
receivers - Clark stop second - go up to
seven where's that where's that turnover
Seattle hasn't turned it over yet and
Ross is just playing a masterful game
feels like their tail the mitt the may
stro the maestro Wilson out of the
shotgun second a goal from the seven
pennies in the game penny with the
handoff picks up a handful they're
running third and goal from the four
need a turnover let's go shout out to
Pete Carroll's nose think that's flat
and shout out to everyone out there
doing nose beers hmm we like the nose
for crack one open Wilson out of the
shotgun third and goal from the four
Metcalf corner of the end zone
back to throw he's got him and down he
goes he's sacked
they never give that to you
Fletcher packs with the sack and now
this is not I mean they'll probably make
it because the game is rigged against me
but 27-yard field goal
I think 27 yarders man the extra point
one dude I feel like the threshold is
like 37 27 yarder from the right hash
maybe a block loading its up no they got
it's good 23 7 Eagles could tie with two
scores and two two points two-point
conversions mark f checking in big
friend of the program he just got his
custom SGP lighters hold and now I can
smoke my weed you guys are awesome there
we go shanty mark shout-out to ya shout
out to the lighters we said hey shout
out to the brats top again they're gonna
be feeding us during the Super Bowl
football tournament wait when's the
Superbowl again July 25th
we're just go to sports gambling podcast
our comm trip Ian ships Saturday
saturday Saturday July 25th starting at
3 p.m. on the west coast 6 p.m. on the
East Coast we're gonna call the NFC
Championship the AFC championship and
the Super Bowl that we can't call the
Super Bowl the big game that's awesome
I'm excited for I'm bringing many nose
of yours there you see that lung
capacity right there that's how I
survive the forest fire you need some
pre-workout the forest fire over the
weekend true story Eagles will take over
on their own 33 down 16 here 11:35 left
to go let's go baby come on shout out to
all the haters peace and love peace and
love shout out the cushy dreams for
keeping me healthy with those CBD
pre-rolls
yeah be like smoke and CBD cuz she
dreams calm promo code sgp 15% off there
once under center first and 10 from the
33 OH
back to throw pull it pass over the
middle come on down to the 48 that's
supposed to be the fumble I need one
more but I need one more before wince
gets a passing touchdown and ruins that
bet first and ten at the 48 eagles in
Seattle territory with the wind at their
back down 16 they definitely have the
advantage here with the wind's hard cap
hand off the mile Sanders nice boy up
the middle he knocked Wagner backward
Sanders having himself a game and yeah I
got eight that was another one I almost
threw out with Sanders over Jesus
I'm just dialed into this sim action
Sean Eagles plus 11 and a half plus 1000
now plus 10 and a half plus 1000 total
is 40 gun to your head
over/under shown over went out of the
shotgun first and ten
pull it past the Earth's getting the
Earth's involved like it said it's got a
hundred great James Woods checking in on
a YouTube ATC who's got the stripper
salt that's a that's a nice alternate
name for nozbe Hurst yeah Zach Ertz 7
for 102 so that easily cashed the over
63 and a half I got you stoie so soft
the okay second it to Wentz out of
the shotgun from the 29 hard count again
back to throw we hit his lineman in the
back again you know at this point what
do you have to lose take a look at the
young guy maybe he's a better fit for
the offense
maybe the players will play a little
harder for him and someone with heart to
me championship pedigree he'd be able to
scramble and grab two yards there I can
tell you that uh yeah I think Jalen
Hertz would it would have gotten more
than seven points that's for sure
when Thunder Center 32 from the 29
back to throw got her you gotta hit up I
mean horrible throw are the D cells
raining down at the link yet cuz Carson
Wentz looks lost does not look like a
princess too expensive to throw these
days t-cells are expensive you get forth
until money our battery oh my god why
are you kicking the field goal makes it
a to score game it's already a pill goes
up and it's good 23:10 928 so they stole
the game alright oh sure yeah they're
mixing it up in there that's decent arm
talent for a kicker the Eagles are gonna
need a turnover to win this game you
throw him back there under center
they're gonna need a turnover to win
this a shout out to dick girths burger
over on YouTube
he's like a 70% Donovan McNabb that's a
that's a serious low blow Sean does not
like that shot not a fan of what take
Hertzberg no Donovan McNabb
I like Mike that and Sean I mean I'll
make fun of them too but and Sean for
those asking who are we last time we are
the sports gambling pipe Charles I'll
answer that when he's Deshawn he's
playing black gene not even looking to
play t-ball yeah no I was I was hooking
up the listeners with a free play so
what ways the ball on the tee I was
saying for the last time tonight for
those asking who are we with the sports
gambling podcasts there we go check us
out on Apple podcasts Spotify stitcher
there you go sport you're feeling better
first and ten from the 25 this is it'll
taken over this is name this isn't the
end of the world Sean sorry sorry : the
internet yeah we're on the Internet yes
we are
pump fake by Wilson looks to run both
loose oh my god of course the lineman
picks it up you come on yes the one
time we have a break
are you kidding me and the Eagles chant
is as if they don't know that they
didn't get the ball
those those he fumbled it right to the
guy I think they were trying to call
fumblerooski man zette Dean Stein cooler
Dean Stein cooler Wilson under center
second and 15 clocks running hand it off
to Carson not much there listen you're
gonna this is gonna be a sweater that's
right on the edge there
third and 13 gotta throw it in that wind
right now shout-out to the ACE gang hot
shoulders checking in on YouTube ATC say
McNabb underrated well he should have
kept his treadlow interesting
interesting tank i like that take but
not underrated but the dreadlock tape
circuit it's third and 13
Oh dangers we gonna fly Jalen Mills you
gotta pick that off boy on the wind this
punt is gonna go nowhere for thisor
tonight us dude there's a lot of
time left
that's why you got to keep it on the
ground there on third and 13
yeah I think they were trying to get a
first down
McJob was great this better than they
can I agree these are the rules the
world of course wat wat own end of the
wind song can I get the cash register
please because I did catch that tyler
lockett prop we think earlier so i'm
down i only have a couple bets left that
don't have a circle around them sean i
may have a clean sweep tonight Kramer is
red hot red hot it's crazy that I'm
giving you these pics and you can bet on
one side of the shotgun first and ten
Wagner throw it Jesus Christ throw the
ball alright bring in the backup
I mean at this point why don't you bring
in bring in hurt so cuz he sucks second
at 16 yeah you're right this guy's
playing well what his legs should be
able to just keep him in the game at
least right I don't know why is once not
running
he's scared again that's been running
scary ran that one time also it's a
video again second and 16 from the 26
once out of the shotgun screen mile
Sanders gets a block turns up field oh
all right picked up some third and 10
just get it keep going to Earths
Clark's starting to be an issue here
seven minutes they're down two scores
yeah need to pick up the pace here third
and ten get it to Earth's look at him
he's right there
come on let's head of the shotgun that
could have been they got a go here may
not gonna go for it they're gonna punt
the game no the game's completely soft
no I mean they don't they don't go for
when they obviously should so annoying
there you go Shan fourth and 10
yeah let's go and you got to go first
because they're not even in field goal
range it got it oh wow Sean just enough
speed what kind of coverage was that
unhook your trailer bro kind of coverage
pursuit of 210 or fourth and ten
whatever the Sanders the lone back once
under center keep this clock running
back to throw get they're gonna bake the
towers puts it in I know he's sure tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick Jesus
Christ okay run it now running now don't
need a chance no no just run run guy
[Music]
thrown the ball second ago from the one
hardcamp
throwing it again big balls
what are you jesus christ what a
huge tackle though because now a minute
went off the clock your best player
ismail santa's give them the ball four
times don't overthink it they're getting
cute third and goal from the one the
Philly special Flint's added the shotgun
no way fools isn't playing where's he go
Sanders up top oh he's wide open just
throw it what oh my god he's wide open
[Applause]
[Music]
goddammit this is crazy
he was like it's incomplete pass Peter
fourth and goal from the wand Anton yeah
okay hens and off the mile Sanders
anything Jesus Christ
[Applause]
[Music]
here's the two-point conversion no
[Applause]
database still needs that upgrade that's
why you should have gone for it the
first time but whatever all right Sean
oh man this is a hell of a game this is
why you watch simulated sports this why
you tuned in to the football tournament
presented by the sports gambling podcast
my bookie Dynegy promo code TFT and of
course all things comedy eagles plus 450
on the money line seahawks my hug huge
number huh what are they gonna drop a
spread Seattle hasn't turned the ball
over how does that happen how are we
gonna go through a game where they don't
turn it over I mean going into the wind
this is concerning it's very concerning
massively massively concerning right now
massively concerning out of the end zone
Seahawks will take over plenty of time
left on the clock person 10 from their
own 20 5 Eagles down 6 here Sean you
have a hope and a prayer I have both
that's what I said a hope and a prayer
let's go baby I didn't say a hope or a
prayer Wilson
under center I formation first and 10
are they gonna hand it off hand it off
to Carson picked up for wanting so much
sweating things not going Jones way he's
on the number right now right yeah he
needs a half yard to go over or he could
lose some it's true
second and six Wilson out of the shotgun
[Applause]
hand it off to Rashad Penny get the
first down and then so you locked up
with a being petty
well if Sean's gonna get a break I'm
glad that's the break and not not a
Carson lunch Pat passing votes dude the
illegal hands illegal touching with mile
Sanders was uncovered in the end zone
first and ten now 3:45 left to go Eagles
neither gonna stop here can't give up
another first down Wilson out of the
shotgun
pin it off to Carson that's it probably
got it there yeah second and six you
need a loss though you need one of those
weird broken tackles where he Jukes
backwards that happens yep I'm second in
six from the 49 two more first downs
over right Wilson out of the shotgun
yeah three time outs in the two-minute
warning still hard count by Wilson hand
it off to penny
huge hole at the middle what are they
doing why they not playing the run first
you can because the Seahawks need to get
in field goal range where they missed
the field one they probably would miss
the field that's what's gonna happen
Eagles are gonna get it get a missed
field goal turnover how we going the
whole game with no turnover come on
Eagles defense is soft
Wilson under center
person ten hand it off to Carson breaks
it to in move brakes and tackle picks up
a couple eagles moneyline now second
seven 500 hello
tickets to the two-minute warning oh man
yeah it is interesting because they're
at a spot where they would you know
another 10 yards or so they're in no
man's land because they cannot make a
film on the win again you need to get to
the 20-yard line I believe yeah being
field but if they get down there they
probably can run the clock out
Wilson under center and then formation
second and seventh but they'll still try
here because they're idiots
oh great tank we lost yard zone he did
he needs to lose a few more yards though
yeah but that's a good start they're not
gonna show us oh there you go
he lost two yards so he's gonna be at 62
maybe I think it's 6161
I think you need him to lose two more
yards yeah 39 from the 42 I formation
we need your ear for the Seahawks we're
on the ball you need penetration from
Cox that's Jesus is that the game no not
the field goal
not quite the whole option here well
it's a first down but they what they
have two timeouts or one one timeout
plenty yeah it's not over didn't Seattle
kick the long field goal it's not over
yet though if they get another first
down its game Jesus come on no turnovers
for the Seahawks who's on the sticks
who's on the sticks
Wilson under center
[Applause]
the action no don't go to lock it okay
okay then I think that's it Wow okay so
I cash on the luck and I cash on the
running for were crazy juice did I get
the over receptions and you got the
under yards oh good job buddy
yeah and the Eagles lost which do you
know here I just I just I don't want to
say it yet but I'm all square with Shawn
stack in the morning Green sim God
engaged Wilson back to throw though
Jesus they don't know they don't know
until under a minute that they won the
game so they might throw it one more
time well they're gonna run one more
play before they realize they can end
the game so we Mike you know Sean might
have a chance so I still could lose
where was the turnover no turnover he's
passing again Sean second and goal I
think they're gonna this is maybe the
end of the game
should've let him score the game's their
goal they're gonna have time but it's
gonna be a nine-point game now I don't I
don't think they'll well maybe they'll
say if they run the ball they could just
send the game
yeah what are you talking about zero
turnovers and that's beautiful city but
a ski thing that didn't cost me a bet
losing that yard there by Russ that'll
do it
thank you everyone for tuning to the
football tournament
kou-kun dundee comes through presented
by the sports gambling podcast my bookie
dad AG promo code TFT oh they're kicking
the field goal that matter for anyway
for the old on 23 did anyone just get
ripped that is a that is a crazy swing
wait was that that was that had to be a
total at some point I'm gonna have over
forty one and a half
that's why you stay tuned to the last
second of the football tournament Kaku
and for the sports gambling podcast i'm
shawn second the muddy green and he is
Ryan I'll see everyone oh is it a week
from tonight Shawn come the football
tournament forward all right tomorrow
night my bookie Matt and twitch sports
gambling podcast which see everyone
tomorrow night Kramer let it ride
[Applause]